okay the hour being at 10 o'clock
basically we're turning today over to
the Department of Education
and so you all have decided who's going
to go where and when and all that kind
of stuff so I'll just say whoever's on
please come forward and do whatever it
is we're going to listen to
good morning for record I'm Caitlin
Davis from the Department of Education
and we have a variety of presentations
today on behalf of the Department of
Education for some of the programs that
we oversee that are funded in the
education trust fund on the agenda today
tentatively first up we'll start with
career and Tech education and
transportation
related to those programs the next item
we have up on our agenda is special
education depending on timing
um and like in the morning we also plan
to discuss lease Aid and public school
infrastructure fund now that might get
pushed into the afternoon just kind of
depending on how many questions and
whatnot you all have for for the
department and then in the afternoon
we're going to spend an intensive period
of time going over the education funding
formula and how it relates to the
various different recipients of those
education of that education funding
um so I think so you'll hear from each
of the staff that operate the programs
at the department and I think they'll
pretty much take questions as you all as
we go the point of today is for you all
to have a good understanding of how the
programs work and operate at the
Department of Education so that in about
a month from now when you start going
into this really heavy budget
discussions you have a general
understanding of the program works and
then so you can really just focus on
what are the impacts of various
decisions rather than trying to take
that time then and understand the
programs so each staff I think has some
handouts for you and we'll go through
those over the course of the day but you
know stop us let us know you have any
questions and you know we're all here to
support the committee so with that I'm
going to turn it over to Jeff beard
who's the administrator of the career
and Tech education Bureau
thank you Mr chairman and and uh
Representatives on the committee
um I'm Dr Jeff beer does Caitlin
mentioned I'm the state director for CTE
and the bureau administrator for the
Bureau of career development at the
Department of Education what I want to
do is just give a brief overview of
Career and Technical education and three
major sources of funding for programs in
CTE
so if you go to the first page of the
the handout CT is shorthand for Career
and Technical education we have about 30
CT centers that are Regional centers
located in high school public high
schools across the state in addition to
that there are CTE programs at the 70 uh
the seven community college is in the
ccsnh system CT includes a really wide
range of programming everything from
business building construction trades
Automotive trades cosmetology
Public Safety and criminal justice the
general I.T cluster engineering Advanced
manufacturing Health Sciences and really
it's an essential driver for the state's
economy it's a steady stream of skilled
knowledgeable workers that can go into
businesses across the state and provide
their their competence to help with the
employment pipeline
importantly
um CT programs I'll quote myself here CT
programs prepare kids to be able to
enter into that job market with minimal
of the job training so the idea is that
by going through our typically two-year
Career and Technical education programs
that kids would be able to take an
entry-level job at a company crucially
in the state of New Hampshire because we
want to as we know we've had
historically an out migration problem we
want to keep kids here we want to have
them have well-paying jobs they can then
contribute to the tax base by buying
homes and uh
in in our communities
um on the next page there's a
unfortunately somewhat blurry map that
shows the uh the distribution of the
regional CT centers and the Community
College
Programs across the state
our most recent CT Center just came
online last year up in Colebrook uh the
North Point CT Center
before I go into talking about the
Perkins Federal funding does anyone have
any general overview questions about
Career Technical Ed
yeah I have a question about
I don't remember what it's called the
fast start or where you could go when
you're in high school you could go to
the local Community College do these
courses qualify as credit for those
programs absolutely yeah the the the
program that the Community College uh
has is called Running start
um and it provides young people the
opportunity to earn
um college credit while still in high
school one of the requirements of CTE
programs in New Hampshire at the high
school level is that young people are
able to earn either apprenticeship hours
hours towards licensure or college
credit while they're in high school so
that's one thing that's an integral part
of of CT
thank you and just just a quick question
in terms of you know ice obviously this
is an alternative to going to college
for the kids that decided you know a
college degree is not really what they
are interested in and there will always
be you know not everybody needs to be a
college graduate
in your experience how close to being
ready to take a you know skilled job you
know are kids that finish uh you know
the city you were mentioning with
minimal on-the-job training where are
they you know in general terms are they
pretty much there and they just need a
bit of training to get the specific
needs of the employer or will they you
know is it the equivalent of getting two
years but they still in the significant
amount of support well uh to be honest
it's really a yes and proposition
um it CT is not an alternative city is a
is part of a career planning Career
Development process so a young person
could come out of some of our programs
ready to go immediately into a job a
good example would be young people that
go through health science programs earn
an LNA can work as a licensed nurse
nursing assistant right out of high
school our Auto Tech program students
will come out and are able to work at a
dealership uh working on cars
on the other hand we have programs like
biotechnology and computer programming
where there's probably some
post-secondary piece they're going to do
they could go into and again one of the
requirements is that there is the
possibility of
entering immediately into a job however
there are some
um some fields that require some
post-secondary Education and Training
whether it's apprenticeship for the
trades most students come out of our
building construction trades programs
Electrical Plumbing construction with
some hours towards their apprenticeship
but they're not full apprentices and
they're certainly not Journeymen at that
point so there's going to be some
Education and Training that happens
after high school
foreign
absolutely work-based learning is one of
the requirements for CTE programs in New
Hampshire so there has to be some kind
of internship during the time that a
Young Person's in the program some of
those involve employers coming into
schools and supervising work which is a
simulated internship but we really
encourage the gold standards really
community-based authentic internships so
absolutely every single program has some
aspect of earlier before we started a
session we're talking a little bit about
teacher education and there are teacher
education programs in the CTE centers
that include student teaching so young
people whether they're deciding to work
with preschool-aged kids or Elementary
or middle school aged kids have an
opportunity within their school district
to go out and assist teachers learn
about instruction assessment all the
things that the teachers do so
internships and work-based learning is
an essential component of CTE
thank you
thank you Mr chair
um maybe this isn't the time but at some
point will you speak about some of the
programs that have closed and why they
were closing I'm thinking particularly
the automotive program at Portsmouth
High which I think was shut down so if
you can give a sense of which programs
are growing which programs are not doing
well and perhaps your sense of why
either now or later on yeah absolutely
representative happy to happy to speak
to that the uh the decision
um is uh made at the local level so
whether or not to to keep a a course or
program of study running is really based
on local decisions at the state level
when we bring new programs on the first
thing that we look at is the economic
feasibility
the commissioner of education has the
authority to approve new programs uh at
this at the local and state level we
don't shut programs down at the state
level if the local Says student interest
has waned over time
um we are having difficulty it's very
difficult to get CTE teachers because at
the end of the day CT teachers are
career Changers so they're people that
have made the decision to no longer work
and they're often much more lucrative
fields to become teachers and train up
the next generation of of of kids
what we will do at the department is
often encourage centers to really look
at the economic need to say in the
example of Automotive or in the example
of advanced manufacturing which is a
major sector in our state
consider what you can do to keep that
program online because it is so
essential to the economic growth
all right uh so a major source of
federal funding for CT programs in New
Hampshire is Perkins and if you'll go to
the next page after the uh the state CTE
map the official term is strengthening
CT for the 21st century act each year
New Hampshire gets about six million
dollars in funding that funding is based
on demographic data so when octay which
is our federal partner determines the
the funding they really base it on
population
interestingly enough the entire New
England region gets about the same
allocation so Maine New Hampshire
Vermont we all get six million dollars
so we have about comparable populations
and we distribute the allocations to
leas or to the regional CTE centers
really based on a formula uh so it's
really the number of kids between the
ages of 5 and 17 served in the region
that are in poverty and that's based on
that safe data which is the the small
area
um economic income and poverty
data that's provided by the U.S Bureau
of the census and then that's divided by
the total number of kids between the
ages of 5 and 17. that gives the the
allocation for each Center that goes out
so it's not based on
um enrollments it's not based on number
of programs or types of programs it's
strictly based on demographic data and
not just on the demographics of the town
in which the center is located but the
surrounding towns that the center serves
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question uh does does that
include rehab of these uh centers uh CT
centers and I imagine that would be
extra and where are we at as far as the
number of centers that we've rehabbed
I'm glad you asked that I'm going to get
to that later on because that's a
separate program those funds are State
funds that go to that the renovation and
the construction
but I but I will cover that in some
detail in in a little bit down the line
crucially
um only leas and the community college
system of New Hampshire are eligible
recipients of these funds that's per the
ACT those are considered the the local
um CTE schools per the definition of the
law Once Upon a Time Carl Perkins
awarded
scholarships I'm a recipient actually of
one I got my cigs at UNH and my Master's
at UNH
um on a full
assistantship do they still do things
like that I mean we need to encourage
more people to go into education
especially CTE it was a great perk for
me they even offered me to go get to
continue to go to Ohio State to get my
doctorate at that time I couldn't do it
but
um so do they still do things like that
the the possibility to set up
scholarship funds the capacity is there
I'm going to talk in a moment about the
the way that the the funding gets
distributed and there are some State
leadership activities that we're
required to spend funds on but any
recipient could decide to set up a
scholarship fund including ccsnh
they receive about a million dollars
annually from
this grant
so the the breakdown of the Perkins
funds of the approximately 6 million
oh
sorry
dangerous territory but it was apropos
you know Mary made me think of it a
little bit going using some of this for
your graduate work
um the way this is written there's an
implied assumption that
poor kids need ctes more in than other
students
um
is that just an implied assumption is
there another way of doing it or is
there there it's a I just made the
thought makes me a little bit
uncomfortable because there may be other
kids who would like to go into a career
and it's not because you know they're
like from a poor area can you just kind
of correct me in my thinking here and
how these things are distributed or
thought about that's a great question in
terms of access New Hampshire is really
dedicated to making sure that everyone
has access to CTE we acknowledge that
it's a valuable opportunity for career
development for any kid no matter of of
zip code or where they're coming from
the um the way that the the funding
allocation does work out is because it
is based on population and demographics
which again is prescribed in in the law
in the federal law it tends to be this
combination of population density and
number of people in poverty so
Manchester quite frankly will always get
the largest allocation because it's the
largest community it has the largest
percentage of people in poverty
um that said there are a number of other
communities
um Wolfeboro being one that has a
regional CT center that is a relatively
affluent area that's serving a large
number of students so the the access and
the ability to access high quality
programming is
um is definitely something that that we
strive for across the state and as I
talk a little bit more in the future
about transportation that does become a
challenge but by and large the the
ability to access CT is not impeded by
where
where someone lives
yeah thank you if I just sort of add
there's I try to get past that
assumption that these schools are for
those kids who aren't smart enough to go
to college which was an old you know
bromide and to get past that uh that
that basically that prejudice that I
think sticks with us a little bit yeah
that's well said and that is something
that does that does persist uh something
that the CT centers and the directors
have been very involved in as the
department has been as well is really uh
trying to convey to decision makers who
are going to be parents that CTE is a
great option for anyone and that it will
always give someone an advantage over
someone who has not taken part in CTE
there's a large number there's some
national level data about
um college going for young people who
have been through CT versus not and uh
70 of CTE participants do go on to to
some level of two or four-year College
which is not to say that that is that
the necessarily the desired outcome it's
really whatever
um wherever someone finds himself on
their career development
pathway it should be something that
meets their their interests their needs
and their ability to participate in the
economy thank you for being sensitive to
that you're welcome
so the way that the the Perkins
breakdown works and this this gets a
little tricky so I'm happy to entertain
some questions about it but essentially
um there's five percent of that six
million is used for administrative costs
by the Department of Education so it's
things like my salary the the cost of of
leasing our suite of offices
telecommunications it's really sort of
what you might think of as indirect
costs
um and that again that's prescribed in
in Perkins you can use five percent or
you states have to use five percent of
their Perkins allocation for
administrative costs
then there's 10 percent used for State
leadership activities so if you think
about it you'd think well uh six million
dollars that's quite a bit of money but
10 of that really is not a whole lot we
end up with about 600 000. of that 10
there are some set of sides that are
prescribed in the law so for example we
have to set aside
um 10 of the ten percent so sixty uh
thousand to prepare uh individuals for
occupations and careers that are
non-traditional for their gender so the
idea would be young women in Auto Tech
young women in welding young women in
construction young men in healthcare
young men in cosmetology young men in in
education
so we have to have some some funds that
we use for that purpose the way that the
state of New Hampshire has done that for
the last two years is we've contracted
with monster in worldwide the uh the job
aggregator to run a series of targeted
social media ads where if someone's say
scrolling through Facebook or Instagram
they'll see or Twitter they'll see an ad
they can click on it and it says here's
information about employment
opportunities and training opportunities
for if say you're a young woman
interested in getting into becoming an
electrician you can connect with that
in addition we have to spend
um a um a set amount it ends up being
000 on State institutions and the way
that state institutions are defined in
the ACT New Hampshire really only has
one which is the Department of
Corrections systems we have the men's
and women's facility here in Concord we
have the facility in Berlin and there's
a a set of CTE
courses and and opportunities that are
happening in each so here in Concord
there's a culinary arts program there's
cosmetology program there's a graphic
design program and there's a general
business program where people learn how
to use Excel word and the basic uh the
basic Microsoft Office things that will
prepare them for employment post
incarceration
um in addition part of our state
leadership funding as you may may know
there's a state law that requires that
every young person in the state take a
career inventory by the end of ninth
grade
um so in order to make that not an
unfunded mandate we're using out of our
Perkins funding money to pay for a way
to which is a career interest inventory
platform it's called awato
any questions about the state leadership
before I go on to
okay
um this is the the part that can be a
little confusing so the remaining 85
percent gets distributed to the eligible
recipients uh and there is a split
between the community college system and
uh the high schools so it's a 21 and uh
0.5 it goes to the community college
system uh the remaining 79 and a half
goes to the the Regional High School CT
centers but before that happens we're
allowed to
um in Perkins hold up to 15 of the total
allocation in reserve we've chosen to do
and what we do and again that's 10 of
that total not of the 85 but it gets
held back from the 85.
um so it's about
um it ends up being about uh 500 000
that's held in reserve
what we do with that is we distribute
that in the form of uh competitive Grant
competition
um that we do twice a year once in the
fall once in the spring the purpose of
this grant competition is to fund
activities at the regional CT centers or
the community college that increase the
number of Industry recognized
credentials earned by uh by students so
industry recognized credentials are ircs
include things like licenses badges
certificates an apprenticeship card
would be an IRC essentially an IRC is
something that if you have it on your
resume it gets you in line for a job and
gives you some preference over a
candidate that does not hold the IRC
and so finally about four million
dollars gets distributed to the among
the 30 Regional CTE centers and then
about a million dollars goes to ccs and
age which then gets distributed among
the seven Community College uh in the
system
so what can they use the funding for
they can use it to buy equipment
professional development for for
teachers promote work-based learning and
the earning of those industry recognized
credentials a large amount of the the
Perkins funding does go to equipment
um I'll talk more about this as we get
into tuition Transportation but CTE is
more expensive than non-cte running a
current technical education program like
an auto program will cost a school
district a great deal more money than
running a math program or an English
program in the same high school so they
do use quite a bit of it for equipment
professional development is an important
piece of this because CTE again has some
unique needs classroom management in a a
busy CTE space where there's major
safety concerns is very different than
classroom management in a non-ct setting
um really important principle and you'll
hear this probably from other folks uh
today that talk about Federal funding
Federal funding has to supplement local
funding it cannot supplant and replace
it so if there was something that was
being covered with local money or
non-federal money in the past you can't
then use federal funds to to then pick
up that cost that's a a general
principle of federal funding
any questions about the Perkins funding
before I go into tuition transportation
thank you so much okay so uh tuition
Transportation uh colloquially known as
TNT
um nine million dollars uh each year
comes from um from the state of New
Hampshire this goes into the general
operating budget of the department
um every student in the state is
eligible for TNT funding so public
school students non-public school
students homeschooled students there is
a a piece in the RSA that that's Rel
related to transportation that does know
the District of residence is responsible
for transportation which is then
reimbursed by the the department so in
the case of non-public school students
or homeschooled students it's where they
live that covers the cost of
transportation to CTE
um transportation is paid to sending
districts first and then the remaining
costs for tuition come later
um and as I talk more about it well
transportation is a fairly significant
cost uh in the in the the last fiscal
year we paid out 682 000 in
transportation costs of that 9 million
tuition cost is a much more significant
cost
but uh crucially the nine million
dollars is used by New Hampshire for
maintenance of effort with uh Perkins so
Perkins has a provision in the act that
says that you must level fund your state
effort if it dips below it we run the
risk of losing the 6 million in federal
funding so what that means is is is if
there is ever an increase in tuition and
transportation it goes above the 9
million dollars it must remain level
funded at whatever the increase is in
order to continue to meet the
maintenance of effort
so again for FY 23 which covered the
2122 school year CTE transportation that
we reimbursed to
sending districts was 682 000 118.33 but
importantly this was based on a rate set
by the New Hampshire Board of Education
um quite a long time ago
um it at least a decade ago the current
rate that's set and this is in in
statute and in rules is 10 cents per
student per mile for a bus
and 25 cents per per mile rather for
self-transporting so in the case of a
young person who's driving themselves to
CTE or their parents dropping them off
it's 25 cents a mile current federal
rate for mileage reimbursement I believe
is something in the area of 60 cents a
mile
uh tuition uh is calculated by a
percentage the doe 25 is that cost per
pupil rate that's calculated annually by
districts
districts choose they look at their
their needs they look at the cost of
running CT programs and they decide is
their rate going to be 20 of that Doe 25
all the way up to 40 percent of that Dua
25. this varies by
um by CT Center and they make the
termination based on a number of factors
including things like energy cost
equipment that they're running supplies
for programs again a welding program
costs more than a teacher education
program in terms of supplies needed
um
the idea is essentially that that CTE is
more expensive than non-ct
so it's it's going to cost more
um or somebody to attend a CTE program
than not attending a CT program because
of the equipment costs the energy cost
the supplies cost so on and so forth
right now the majority of CTE students
attend a high school in which the
regional CT Center is located
so there there are sending school
students that come within regions to go
to CT centers a great example would be
Concord right here the crtc in Concord
they have eight sending high schools
they probably have the most in the state
followed by Seacoast School of
Technology in Exeter which has seven but
really by and large the majority of CTE
students attend the high school in which
the center is located
and in the um the last fiscal year that
we made payments uh 8 million one
hundred twenty three thousand six
hundred nineteen dollars and seventy
seven cents went to tuition payments
thank you Mr chairman right uh can you
can uh sending District split that uh
where they send their students
say if one program doesn't one like
kings would
versus uh Tri-City
one offers certain things and the other
one can I split that yes yeah I'm glad
you asked the uh the way that the the
RSA is written um and then the the
attending and minister of rules is if
the CTE program is not offered within
the the center that that's being served
that a student may attend another Center
and we'll we'll cover those the
department will cover those
transportation and tuition costs
now two quick questions
um if the student attends the high
school which holds the CTE Center do
they still get the tuition or the
transportation reimbursement
they do not there's a couple um
exceptions to that though
um Exeter Manchester Nashua all have
um they don't have high schools that are
sending to the CT sector the CT center
is right there but they do have some
Transportation happening so in the
example of Exeter extra high schools up
the road from SST so they do get
Transportation
reimbursements but in the case of a
student who's walking down the hallway
to to attend CT that they would not get
transportation
and is it time for the Board of
Education to consider raising the
transportation rate if it hasn't been
done and there's such a difference
between what we do and what the federal
government does that's a great question
um there does need to be a change to
legislation representative Ladd has a
bill um in this current session that um
that seeks to do that so it really is a
uh it's a multi-part uh step of the the
the the current law uh directly and the
administrative rule that goes along with
it directly refers to that rate that was
set
um so in order for the rate to be reset
the law has to be amended so it's a sort
of a one two three then we'll be able to
to take a look at that
you're welcome
so quick question on the
tuition rate I just want to make sure I
understood it correctly since it's the
first time I uh you know get exposed to
this the
local authorities that have cd centers
are basically deciding what additional
payments are needed to supplement their
tuition and that's between 20 and 40
percent but it's them who make the
calculations or does the state approve
those because I would assume there's got
to be a check from the state that the
you know increases the requested rate is
reasonable correct every uh every fall
the the schools will submit to us their
proposed rate and then we we approve
that rate but the uh to to clarify the
um the tuition is a percentage of that
Doe 25. it's again it's based on the
idea that the tuition is based on a full
day of school but that young person is
for part of the day going to the CTE
Center yep yep understand one
separate question we were talking
earlier about you know the funding for
the Perkins being the tied to Poverty
rates among other factors and I'm just
trying to understand whether the intent
of that
legislation based on your interpretation
obviously because nobody can read the
mind of the feds but
what's the intent to steer more you know
low-income students into City or just to
adjust for the fact that likely they
would have a harder time thing paying
for it and make those opportunities
available to everybody but send more
financially to the people who need
financial aid rather than to you know
the people who need financial aid less I
believe the latter is the intent is to
to make more opportunities available and
that again acknowledging that CTE can be
an expensive proposition it was intended
to give some some assistance to leas so
that they can provide high quality CT
thank you you're welcome
thank you Mr chair and thanks for taking
my question I'm a newbie here so I
apologize for a really Elemental
question I'm about to ask you could you
explain doe 25 what is that I can
attempt to okay
Caitlin may be able to fill in the
blanks a little bit on this but
essentially there's a per pupil uh raid
that's set by every uh Lea across the
state and the doe 25 is is essentially
this is the cost per pupil here's how
much it costs to educate a young person
at our school
nuances I'm sure just a quick question
could you
um tell me the um enrollment across the
state for uh the total well CTE centers
oh absolutely uh representative
um we fluctuate between 9 500 and 10 000
students and we're pretty
um and I've looked at the the 10-year uh
Trend and it's generally speaking around
9 500 students
um there was a little shift about five
years ago where there was a law that was
introduced previous to that you had to
have completed two years of high school
before entering CTE when the law was
amended it allowed young people to enter
after completing one year of high school
but we still have yet to see a
significant bump in part of the reason
for that is that young people have so
many graduation requirements that they
need to fulfill that when they are able
to consider CTE they have to make sure
that they've satisfied English math
science so on and so forth
now you have another question because
what you just said years ago I used to
work in CTE
um it was called
something different back then
um but one of the things that was my job
was to align certain vocational classes
for academic credit for example um in I
did a biology credit for Health Sciences
and we did um oh just a a math credit
for uh lead the way does that happen
because that just seems like a simple
way to encourage more kids to go where
they'd get the dual kind of credit for
participating in those courses I'm glad
you asked that question absolutely it
happens uh quite a bit
um and something that will help with
that is HB 1661 was passed last
legislative session it allows for a
requirement that's in the regional CTE
agreements that requires a statement of
how local districts will accept evidence
of Competency and then award partial or
full credit toward graduation for things
that are completed in CTE
um I do have an additional piece and for
whatever reason when I printed off my
packet it looks like it was left off so
I'm gonna I'm gonna grab my uh attache
and see if it's in there because I do
want to talk about renovation and
construction
yeah I apologize for that for whatever
reason that last part was left off uh my
original test copy had it my copies do
not but I'll give you the overview and
then I can provide it to you at a later
date
so the um the the other major uh source
of CTE funding
um is uh CTE Center renovation
historically that has come from the
capital budget however there's no
requirement in statute that the funding
does come from the capital budget there
there's opportunities for other ways to
fund this
the administrative rules for CTE it's a
1303 is the the actual admin rule
citation
it has it established a priority list
for CTE Center renovation and that's
based on earliest date of construction
to most recent
so the
um the the centers that are still in
line to be renovated there's a current
capital budget request from the
Department for a project in winnesquam
Tilton
and then there's another project that's
proposed for Newport
the um the the major development in
winnerscom is that it was a regional
subcenter so that at one point in
history there were agricultural
sub-centers
Fall Mountain which is over in Langdon
and then winnesquam
had fewer programs and they were
strictly agricultural
they've since expanded so in the last
year wintersquam
applied for their renovation funding and
as part of that renovation funding
request they had asked to include two
new programs so in that in that proposal
they had included an advanced
manufacturing program which is a major
economic need in that area as well as a
cosmetology program just as an aside
cosmetology is is kind of an interesting
program because it doesn't show up in
labor market data and the reason it
doesn't is that labor market data is
largely based on Employment Security
data and employment security data is
based on people paying workers
compensation
so any independent contractors will not
show up in workers compensation data
because they don't
the businesses don't pay pay that
cosmetology licensed cosmetologists
people that cut and style hair do nails
Etc are all essentially independent
contractors and so for that reason when
you go to look at labor market data it
could be a little bit more tricky with
cosmetology than when something say like
Auto technology where you can look at
all the dealerships and see how many
employed that said it's a a well-paying
vital career path and the thing I always
say I said this to House Ed myself
excluded you can tell by looking at me
that I don't go to hair salons a whole
lot but for the most part most people
have been in the last month or so and
just as a sort of anecdotal thing you
can see how busy stylists are
just a quick question seeing how
cosmetology is one of the many
professions that requires a license for
people to be able to earn a living can
you give me an idea of how far along the
licensing path does taking a CTE course
in that get you excellent question all
of our cosmetology programs give someone
one year toward the license so by the
time that the students finish every
student another thing that's a little
unique about Cosmetology in New
Hampshire is that the salons within the
CT centers are licensed cosmetology
salons
and the teachers are actually triple uh
licensed they're licensed as CTE
teachers so they have the state
credential they're also licensed
cosmetology instructors which is a Board
of Cosmetology requirement and they're
also licensed cosmetologists so they
have that triple uh credentialing
there are a couple centers and I don't
want to misspeak but I know that Dover
is one of them where the students come
out with their license so they actually
earn sufficient hours that they can come
out and have the the credential and are
able to start working thank you
yes
so for the um the the renovation
projects uh the um the request is is
based on
um a couple details so the um the state
will pay up to 75 percent of the costs
of renovating a CT Center
the um the priority is based on that
that cue that was established in the
admin rules
but that's predicated on the locals uh
securing 25 of the funding so they have
to do that by vote they have to do that
um in advance of getting approved for
the project what that means is that
sometimes communities don't have
sufficient votes to secure the 25
percent to get a bond and then they move
down uh the queue we have five centers
that have not yet been renovated there's
still up for uh for renovation and in
order Newport and winnesquam which I
mentioned before currently have projects
that are
um in the the process of having funds
requested
then Milford
Claremont
and
and Peterborough thank you so
Peterborough was slated for the next
biennium
um
the the cost of renovating has become a
bit of a challenge over the last two
years as you you can imagine with
construction costs going up so much so
there is a process in place to adjust uh
the request if it comes in at a larger
that was originally estimated but the
way it works is it's based on a
reimbursement so there is a monthly
report that comes to the department
where they will say these are the costs
so we we reimburse for actual costs so
we don't give that 75 that gets funded
we don't grant that to a community up
front it's based on a reimbursement
model where they submit the the actual
costs it gets reviewed by my office and
then we we approve the payment
like uh
additional equipment like let's say uh
like I know Kinks would start a
machinist program or restart a machinist
program now is there any additional
monies provided to buy that equipment
like CNC machines or whatever that's
part of the renovation so again the way
that things are are worded currently is
that the renovation is sort of an All or
Nothing proposition where the entire
Center gets renovated at once that does
include equipment upgrades uh typically
the annual Perkins uh is how most
centers uh fund equipment repairs and
and Replacements if they are approved
for a renovation project they include
all the costs needed to upgrade
um and get new equipment
one thing I miss was your name oh uh Dr
Jeff beard
I think you said it but I didn't have
anything to broadcast
you I think you're winning
uh because my understanding the student
population has
plummeted over the last 10 years and if
you're steady at 9 500 that means you're
ahead of the game
yeah I'm so I'm so glad you noted that
uh representative Emrick it's uh it is
interesting to note that as um as the
student population across the the state
for high school students has continued
to decrease uh CT has remained constant
I think a lot of that is due to uh to
the efforts of uh the CTE community in
raising awareness one thing that we've
done at the department level is really
increased a lot of Outreach and a lot of
direct marketing
um work to parents because parents are
the decision makers the other piece that
we looked at was again going back to our
Perkins funding one of our set of sizes
to recruit members of special
populations there are a number of
special populations including people
with disabilities
um
but a crucial uh segment of a special
population for the state of New
Hampshire are English language Learners
and often just as uh non-english
language learner communities the parents
are the decision makers about education
it's very true about
um about New American and immigrant
communities so doing Outreach in the
form of we took our CTE brochures and
translated them into Spanish Portuguese
Swahili and Arabic which are the four
major language groups of ell folks in
the state made those available to school
counselors to distribute to to families
and to kids so they could be informed
about the possibilities of CTE
thank you
um
with what you just said it popped into
my head are these available for adult
Learners as well if you're having a
career change someone who wishes to you
know go into one of these programs do
you have
um non you know not the young people but
adult Learners representative Murray
your time may not be better uh
so uh the uh the Bureau of adult
education and the career development
Bureau we're we're co-funding a pilot
that we're calling CTE after dark it's a
little bit of misnomer it could happen
during the day it could happen when the
sun's out but the idea is to make
available again because of capacity
issues some of our CTE programs in high
schools can are capped at 14
participants because of safety so an
opportunity could be to offer CTE
programming
um say three to five pm and adult
Learners and high school students could
both work on say an auto shop uh Auto
Tech program a computer science program
so we're funding that over the next year
we have four applicants for the the RFP
that we put out I'm hoping to to pick a
winner and roll out the pilot over the
next school year
okay
thank you very much you're very welcome
thank you thanks for the time
I don't know who's up next
good morning for the record it's Amy
Clark from the Department of Education
um I promise it's not as complicated as
building Aid so I have two other
programs that I'm gonna
talk to you about today I'll wait for
you to get your packets
foreign
so the first packet is Lisa there's two
of them and just the title is at the top
so that's how you'll find it there it's
the skinnier of the two packets
uh
and
um this is just a cover page so my
contact information is there in case
you're ever looking to talk about lisaid
and so the second page is that program
summary again I like to fit my whole
program on one page so if you just need
to go one page here it is uh the
um again contact information the laws
and the rules are there where you'll
find the lease Aid laws also in RSA 198
15 HH section HH
it's just a couple of sentences really
it essentially says so this is buried in
that building Aid law 198 15 is building
Aid So within building Aid there was a
section created in my mind it was
created because we had building aid for
if you owned land and you were going to
build a building then you apply for
building Aid and at some point somebody
said well what happens if you lease a
building so then this part came into
building Aid and it does require a
separate appropriation so keep that in
mind building Aid is one appropriation
lisade is a separate appropriation
and then what lease Aid is really is
it's for uh charter schools are our
school buildings that lease uh most
commonly lease spaces at one time uh
some Career and Technical Education
Centers were included there but now the
regulations separate uh the
appropriation is specific to Charter
Schools so that's what we'll talk about
today so lease Aid is really just those
State Grant funds to help uh school
districts in this case charter schools
with a portion of their lease and that
portion in law is stated as 30 percent
of their lease payment their annual
lease payment up to fifty thousand
dollars maximum that maximum has changed
over the years and we'll talk about that
right in a little bit but that is the
cap on lease Aid currently
uh the funding source I know that we're
here talking about the education trust
fund but the funding source actually is
in the general funds for these uh for
these lease aid funds I think the
thought is to get that transferred over
to the education trust fund eventually
so that's why we're including it today
um the history of lisaid is really it
was created in 2003 but was never funded
until fiscal 20. uh so again put into
law but really nobody applied we had no
funds for it in the first appropriation
came in fiscal 20. and then there's that
little table there I'm just going to
take you through that table I think it
pretty much tells you that all the
history of Lisa that you're going to
want to know uh First Column is fiscal
year
second column is how much the
legislature appropriated
you can see it's two hundred thousand
dollars and then five hundred thousand
dollars thereafter uh then the third
column is the number of schools that
applied for lease Aid
and unlike building Aid it's not a first
come first serve it's everybody
um gets a portion of the lease Aid that
was appropriated so everybody gets 30
percent up to 50 000 if we don't have
enough money everybody's prorated across
the board
um the the big the first big number
column there I guess it's the fourth
column is the total amount of eligible
lease payments this isn't the grant
amount this is the actual eligible
amount of lease payments
um similarly to school building
construction things like maintenance are
not included in building Aid similarly
in leases we have to go through and have
them separate any kind of Maintenance
costs so maintenance costs are not are
one example of things that are not
eligible for lease Aid so if you
subtract out of those things we received
on in fiscal 20 we received 20
applications with 2.5 million dollars of
uh annual lease payments seeking a grant
the next column is the actual amount of
Grant if
um
if we had enough money so those 20
applications for fiscal 20 were seeking
000 we only were appropriated two
hundred thousand dollars so all the
payments across the board were prorated
down to 44 everybody received 44 of
their payment
if you want to know what the shortage is
that year we were short 252 000
um so the next fiscal year there was an
adjustment made
um you can see the next year was five
hundred thousand dollars 16 schools
applied and right across the board that
year they were requesting 382
000 we had enough to make that payment
so we actually paid everybody what the
law allowed and we weren't short any
money
um some and I you know I can take you
through all four rows but I I think you
can see the picture there a couple of
things to note
um some odd numbers that might jump out
at you fiscal 20 to fiscal 21 why do we
have 20 leases and then the next year
only 16.
um it's a com it's not like four schools
just dropped off the it was actually a
combination of things
I think two schools closed uh and I
think three schools purchased
um one school didn't end up applying uh
so that's maybe like six schools and
then we added a couple of schools so the
difference there is four so for a few
different reasons
and then if you look at the row where it
says total lease amount eligible
um one thing to note is that part of
lease Aid is if you're a first time
charter school and you're starting up
those construction costs to for that
leased building are eligible for lease
Aid and so if you look down that column
you see 2.5 million 2.5 million 2.7 and
then there was a big jump in fiscal 23
of 4.2 million that's because we had a
charter school had about a million
dollars of startup costs 1.1 million
dollars of construction to bring that
building up to for startup costs
interestingly none of that was actually
covered by lease Aid because the cap in
their lease payment 30 in their lease
payment was already fifty thousand
dollars so we really covered the 30 and
none of that construction cost was
actually covered
because it exceeded the cap but that is
why you might see that jump in that
number
and then going through some other notes
um it is
um the cap used to be 30 000 uh for
fiscal 20 and 21. that's why you some of
the proration is a little different but
then the cap
um is now fifty thousand dollars for a
fiscal 22 and 23 and and it's currently
in law at fifty thousand dollars
um and then lastly I guess I'll just
point out that
um some people ask what are we going to
get for the next what are we looking at
forecasting for the next biennium we
have Charter Schools coming on board
um often
um and so we are expecting five new
schools this year we have received their
we know that they're coming but full
applications on all that detailed
information isn't due until September
but if we make rough numbers let me just
assume all five are going to meet that
cap at fifty thousand then we're going
to need an extra 250 000 we have seen
they're preliminary applications and
they're actually instead of 250 000
they're closer to 125 000 due to our
estimates on their spaces that they're
renting uh we also anticipate some
leases aren't the same payment every
year and the increase from 22 23 from
just the group that we're paying on now
was about 100 000 so if we just add all
of those numbers up
um the request for lease Aid is likely
going to be anywhere from 875
000 to a million dollars for Lisa that's
what we're anticipating for
a total Grant amount and then we're just
going to wait and see what the
legislature appropriates based on that
yes thank you so the um the 47 million
dollar grant that was a federal Grant
was for startups
for startup Charter Schools is that
correct is that are we still using that
or is that I believe so that does not
include construction costs is my
understanding
okay
okay thank you
foreign
thank you just a quick question
obviously I'm looking at the table
um
which has quite a few charter schools
that appear to be eligible for release
Aid and are not applying
do we have an understanding why they're
choosing to uh quote unquote leave money
on the table here because
it is rather surprising to me that
somebody who is eligible wouldn't apply
and I'm sure there are reasons why I'd
be curious to you know hear your
thoughts on that uh we have um I'd have
to pull the files on these but we
actually did go back and ask each of
those Charter Schools why they didn't
apply
um let's see there's one two three
there's five schools that look like that
they would be eligible for Lisa that did
not apply uh and it's hard to say so
there's probably two
two hurdles I want to call them hurdles
I'm not sure that they could be fully
defined as hurdles but uh one of them is
that you have to have a lawyer review
your lease and I know that that was one
of the responses that they did not have
a lawyer to review their lease and then
I do know other responses where you have
to have your proper documentation that
you have a certificate of occupancy that
you can have proper permitting for the
space that you're in as well as your
space is a public school remember
charter schools are public schools
they're required to be ADA Compliant and
so part of that proof of ADA compliancy
is that you have had
um an architect or somebody familiar
with the Ada regulations come in and
create a certification that the
statement that the facility is ADA
Compliant and so for new new Charter
Schools we actually require that at
startup but some of these are older
charter schools and didn't provide that
documentation at the time they got out
their Charter
thank you Mr chair one quick follow-up I
am not aware what is the universe of
charter schools in New Hampshire what is
the like total population how many are
we talking about oh that's great
question unfortunately I'm not in the
charter school program so I don't know
but I wonder if
my question more and more every year
[Laughter]
okay and then the last page I have for
you
um is really just a list of all the
charter schools so that'll at least give
you the list of the active Charter
Schools uh and we put them on there
whether they received lease eight or not
and again some are not receiving Lisa
because they own their own buildings
some are um paid forth by other means uh
and um so that kind of gives you their
fiscal 22 fiscal 23 history on here
because of that cap if you take your
your
um lease you divide or the cap which is
50 000 you divide it by that 30 percent
for quick numbers essentially you're at
a hundred and sixty six thousand dollar
lease anything else above that you'll
get capped so if you so let me say that
again if your lease if the school has an
annual lease of greater than 166
666 dollars 66 cents if you're greater
than that that annual payment then
you'll be subject to that cap right I
take 30 of that I'll get fifty thousand
dollars so in this list
um you have essentially five
five schools that are subject to that
cap there might be a couple like there's
a hundred and sixty nine thousand I
think they're you know they get shorted
about 800 bucks because of the cap or
something like that but you have Academy
signs for the design creva strong
foundations The Birches Academy and
Wyndham uh Academy public charter they
those five schools received
substantially less than 30 percent
because they are subject to the cap
um but everybody else uh the cap for the
most part covers their uh the 30 covers
their portion of Lee said
thank you
if um in a small town their public
school closed and they reauthorized the
school as a charter
the lease expenses that the town charges
for that Charter would be covered under
this payment is that correct uh can you
say that again the the if a town had a
school
an elementary school for example and it
closed
but it reopened as a charter
police they would they were leasing the
building from the town
this would cover that
lease I'll have to check to see if
there's any nuances in the law but
essentially it says you know that it
doesn't there's not any exclusions of
who you're paying so if a charter school
was leasing from the town then I'm under
the quick assumption that that would be
a perfectly fine lease setup but again
I'd have to check the rules all right
thank you
okay moving on good
okay so the next uh program that we um
operate in my uh the Bureau of school
facilities is um the safe grants and
um this safe Grant security action for
Education safe grants so think of our
um our safety grants for schools door
locks
um bollards in front of the schools
doors windows things like that that is
our safe grants some bigger projects
under safeguards might be our vestibules
those are large expensive projects but
for the most part safe brands are
schools putting applications in anywhere
from ten thousand dollars to twenty
thousand dollars for an application
maybe maybe more
uh
so on that second page your handout
that's the one page summary of the
program uh you'll find the laws and the
rules
um
safe Brands is really a name for
funds that we can obtain to pay for
secure for secure security projects for
schools
it really started out with the public
school infrastructure fund which is
defined in RSA 19815 Y and Z we can't go
any further I'm told Y and Z and we're
done
um so the that public school
infrastructure fund is defined one of
them just defines uh what it does and
the other one defines the members it's a
pretty straightforward statute and
um the safe Brands essentially try are
trying to Target a public and non-public
schools for school security Improvement
projects the public school
infrastructure fund is a fund a state
fund that's just used for public schools
but safe grants is really any funding
that we can obtain to give out grants
for school security so one of them
recently under funding sources you can
see uh recently we had General funds
through the public school infrastructure
fund of 3.9 million dollars and then we
were also able to obtain
um 10 million dollars of fund funds
through the arpa through the Gopher uh
through the Gopher office so
um you'll see that the safe Brands
really Encompass State funds and federal
funds at this point
when we obtain those federal funds part
of that application was that we would go
through we would use those I'm sorry I
said state but when we obtained those
federal funds that 10 million dollars of
federal funds part of that application
was that we would go through the public
school infrastructure fund process in
obtaining that and which means that we
have a public school infrastructure fund
commission that reviews the projects we
work closely with Homeland Security who
ranks those projects and through that
process they then get recommended to the
Governor from the governor they then go
to Governor Council in fiscal and that's
how they get out to schools
Grant
go ahead yeah thank you uh I know some
schools don't didn't get any second
round money
is there a reason for that they don't
get what what round if you if you look
at the chart
uh
yeah yes well so you notice some most
most got first round money
then you look at the second round
and some didn't get and my town didn't
get second round money and I'm wondering
why they didn't is it because they
didn't apply or what uh no uh well
um
uh so
we can go through that in a second but
there were
557 applications that we've received
that did not receive funding there was
we have an outstanding 21.5 million
dollars of uh requests that were unable
to be funded so there you know there is
a column in there that says whether the
school applied or not so if there's a
number in there but they didn't receive
funds then they didn't receive funding
because of the ranking process uh but or
it could be that they didn't apply if it
said zero along their school
so under the summary of awards how we
tried to keep again safe grants is what
we're
um you know schools don't always
um
care where the funding comes from it
might have some different requirements
along along there but it's for security
projects so the first round of funding
that we released was for using State
funds so that first round schools
applied just Public Schools were
eligible because that came from State
funds which is through the public school
infrastructure fund which is just for
public schools and then the second round
everybody who didn't receive a grant
under the first round was bumped to the
second round we opened up the
application process again we've received
new applications we granted out that 10
million dollars of federal funds to
school districts including public
schools and non-public schools and those
Awards actually are just getting to
schools right now so schools will just
be starting you can see amount paid is
very little at this point because
actually there's a grant agreement
notification that is due uh tomorrow so
there are some deadlines that are just
starting for schools
um and so those numbers will be more
robust next time we talk about the safe
grants but the money at this point has
all been allocated the 3.9 million
dollars of State funds and the 10
million dollars of federal funds with
the exception of some um you know it's
not we do have a like 40 or 50 000 that
the commission is holding off for some
potential Amendment requests they kept
that buffer instead of breaking into
another category of projects
um
when we talk about school security
projects there's usually three types of
projects that we talk about we talk
about access control we talk about
surveillance and we talk about emergency
alerting so you can kind of think about
in in the security world you know you
have access control trying to prevent
people to get access to the school you
have surveillance surveilling the school
for any
um with cameras and things like that and
then any kind of alerting that you need
to do to your uh to the police
department so those are kind of the
three categories almost all of the
security projects fall into one of those
buckets uh the first round of funding
um they were given to access control
surveillance and emergency alerting
projects but with that 10 million
dollars of federal funds part of that
application was to through gopher was to
focus on access control so if a project
didn't rank high enough some of it was
that it wasn't the category that
Homeland Security kind of rose to the
highest level of a type of project
um and then on the last page or set of
pages is just a breakdown by School
District the number of applications the
total amount that they requested where
they received whether they put an
application in for round one whether
they got funding or not and then same
thing for round two and then same thing
for whether their project wasn't funded
at the very last page
you can see the totals on the bottom
and again I I guess I just want to point
out looking at at the the very last page
on the totals we've received um one
thousand over a thousand applications
requesting over 35 million dollars of
projects the grants do cover 100 of the
grant so but they did cap it uh they
meaning the public school infrastructure
fund did cap the projects at a hundred
thousand dollars per school so
um one school requested to build a
vestibule that cost over a million
dollars if they receive that Grant it
would have been just a hundred thousand
dollars uh for that Grant
and then you can see across the board in
the round one 168 schools were awarded
almost 3.9 million dollars
there is a little column there that just
talks about
um how much was not uh funded because of
that cap and then in round two same
thing but what I really want to call
your attention to
um is the of those 1060 applications 557
were not funded it just goes to show
that it was a competitive process
through this and Homeland Security did
work to rank these projects and the
total that is kind of left on the table
right now unfunded is that 21.5 million
dollars
and that is the summary of that program
if you have any questions I'm happy to
try to answer them
right thank you
foreign
there is
okay
if you'd introduce yourselves please
good afternoon my name is Rebecca
Fredette I'm the state director of
special education
I'm Lisa Moody um I'm an administrator I
oversee data and finance for special
education
all right please sure
yeah sure so I'm Rebecca Fredette
Fredette like Fred and e-t-t-e
and I'm the state director of special
education
sure I will remember that I'm Lisa Moody
video
[Laughter]
I always see data in finance
for special education
okay so I um have I gave you two
handouts the first one is the
information we're going to go through
and then the second one is a history of
special education Aid how much we've
paid out and um what rate we've paid
them out at for proration
so we have um and I'm going to do a
brief overview and then we'll get into
discussion of special education Aid as I
understand that's the primary topic
today so we um are governed by idea New
Hampshire chapter 186 C and then the
standards for the education of children
with disabilities which is the Ed 1100
So Lisa is the administrator for the
office of finance and data management
and she provides fiscal management over
and her team over our fiscal Ida funds
oversight and disbursement of our state
level funds for special education Aid
and court ordered placements she ensures
the implementation of policies and
procedures for the financial
requirements gathers reviews and
analyzes Special Education data for the
integrated monitoring activities our
federal reporting and any programmatic
decisions that we make
she also completes the annual
application for federal funds and then
prepares and submits the annual state
performance plan annual performance
report to the federal government with
our 17 indicators so that's just a
little of what they do
the next slide is just a breakdown of
how many students as of October 1st 2022
how many students we have in special
education and it's broken but down by
disability the next slide gives you the
key for Disabilities so it tells you
their age how many are in each
disability for a total of 30 917 kids
um
I think it's
I want to say like a percentage of
special ed for overall I want to say
it's right in the 1718 yeah
yeah it's in this yeah so it's it's
right around 17 18. I I will say that um
one of the questions we do get is that
our number of special education students
has played stayed fairly static for the
last 20 years
um that's some data that we have online
so it's gone up a little down a little
but not any higher than about 31 000 and
not any lower than about 28 000 so it's
it's been which was that the percentage
17 18. it's about 17 18 yep so if you're
22 yeah
yes we are
you're right if you're at if you're
still at 17 or 18 that means the deity
Community is increasing because the
student population is declining yes
okay
um so at the bottom of page three I've
broken down all the funds that we um put
through our office of finance and data
management we do receive our idea funds
um the first pot of money is for grades
K through 12 or 5 through 21 that's 53
million for Ida preschool and this is
targeted at three and four year olds
it's 1.6 million we did receive some ARP
funds through the covid relief money and
we received 9 million for our K-12 and
about 800 000 for our preschool
the state funding starts with special
education we have about 210 000 there
and then special education Aid is it
about 33 million and our court ordered
placement funds are at 2 2 million we
also have the co-curricular fund that is
about 50 million that one just passed
last year 50 000 oh not 50 million whoa
now does this include DD uh individuals
up till age 21 this includes all yep all
disabilities inclusive of 21. okay so
that it goes all the way up to your 22nd
birthday now after legislation that was
passed last year okay thank you
how much did that cost yeah the the
extra year extra year we will know um
this summer when we receive all of their
submissions for reimbursement one of the
parts of the bill that passed last year
was that we would pay for any extra
funds that the districts incurred
because the bill passed after they had
already done their budgets so when we
received special education Aid
applications we will also receive those
applications for those students that
turned that were 21 turning 22 over the
past year so we're not really sure how
much we will have
okay thank you Mr chairman
um
you uh yeah now I lost it I lost my
train of thought
I'll come back all right we'll Circle
back go ahead okay
so then if we go to
um page yep
I apologize
um court ordered placements yep I'm
gonna talk about that right now oh good
okay I'll be quiet yeah it's on page at
the top of page four one of our state
funds is um for court ordered placements
and these are provided um to districts
for those children in placement for
which the Department of Health and Human
Services has financial responsibility so
if dcyf or DHHS goes through the court
system to place a child this fund will
assist those districts with paying for
some of those funds once the district
has reached three times the estimated
State average expenditure per child or
cap which is right around 60 000 this
year all expenses beyond that are
covered by this court ordered placement
fund so districts will throughout the
year they will submit invoices to us to
say we've reached cap now and showed
that they've reached cap and then asked
for us to pay the remaining portions of
that the whatever they need for an out
of District placement or services or
whatever goes beyond that sixty thousand
um I did write this year's cap is and I
did not put it on there but it is right
around 60 000. and then
um I also wrote last year we paid out so
it's not actually paid out a little over
three million over three million just
over three million and that's on the
page where I listed out all the
um funds that we have
the three million well that's what was
budgeted yeah to what was budgeted was
two million and then we added one and
then we added more money
my question is with regard to
the current situation with YDC if in
fact
we don't act and those kids all have to
be placed someplace would this fund be
the fund that paid for that if they are
placed by the courts yes okay thank you
chairman
when these kids turn 22 now yep all
right do you coordinate with DHHS or
somebody to help them along
just beyond the uh age 22 because they
effectively fall off a cliff right so
the districts um it's that's done at the
district level and the district should
be reaching out to their local area
agencies and coordinating with them as
well as coordinating with VR
um we have been working collaboratively
with VR to develop a system whereby they
have more people within schools and
assisting and we're trying to support
them with that but it is a district
responsibility to that's that transition
plan that they should be developing and
accessing area resources for that child
is that part of the IEP
the transition plan yes is part of the
IEP thank you
thank you
um
you have you once a district has reached
three times the estimated State average
how often do how often does it exceed
that and is this a do you think this is
a reasonable formula for what you're
dealing with now or do is it very
frequently that this that the schools ex
um exceed the state average
so um it's been running about 100
students and with the court order funds
it doesn't lap so the court order funds
if we don't have enough to pay then we
put in uh request to receive more money
and so that we continue to pay for the
invoices so it's not like spend it's not
like um special education Aid where we
just have a budget with
um with court order there's a law that
says that we'll they'll replenish the
money so this is a reasonable statement
this is not
foreign
that's why I'm here
well the question is how many how many
kids do we have in court ordered or out
of District placements total around the
state I mean so court ordered is right
around 100 students but that's only the
ones that reach cap there may be other
students that are court ordered but they
don't reach that sixty thousand dollar
cap but we reimbursed for um 100
students last year
and What's the total for the uh Auto
districts out of District I would have
to look that number up for you okay
because that's pretty important
no he means in general out of District
but you're you're mean over the entire
population of special education how many
of them are out of District okay
okay because all of the court ordered
placements were out of District okay
so then the next one we have is the
special education Aid fund um this one
is provided to districts for children
whose services are con considered high
cost
um the state reimburses districts at 80
percent for any costs that are 3.5 times
the estimated cost per pupil
so once they get to that sixty thousand
dollars after that we will pay them at
eighty percent of what is um what is
required after that the state also
reimbursed versus districts at a hundred
percent for any costs over 10 times the
cap so if they get to six hundred
thousand dollars then we would start to
cover at a hundred percent
um there is typically not enough funds
in the account and reimbursement is
typically prorated which is on that last
sheet that I provided to you
so on the next page um special education
Aid State funds we did a little diagram
to show an example of a student that
costs 155 000
so which we minus the cap so that ninety
two thousand dollars that's everything
that's above cap that's what gets Pro
that's what gets divided out by the
eighty percent so if we had enough funds
the state would pay eighty percent of
the ninety two thousand
which we we would end up paying 73 and
then the district would be responsible
for the 18
000.
the 18 000 the 73 add up to the 92 000
that's above cap and so and then so if
we had enough funds that 155 000 student
the district would end up paying 82 000
and the state would end up paying 73
000. this year we did not have enough
funds we paid out at 98
so instead of 73.6
000 we paid 72.3 000 for that student
and the district ended up having to pay
another thousand the difference towards
that student so they ended up paying 82
640 641 dollars
any questions on that
okay sorry a very quick question in a
previous slide I've seen the same amount
referred to as cap and ecbb are those
just two different terms used to look at
the same number or are they two
different numbers that are close enough
to each other that I
so court ordered is three times and
special education Aid is three and a
half times right but
I I understand that difference but again
uh the cap
referred on the I'm talking about the
page four of your handout in the top
part we talk about the cap number that's
around 60 then we talk about an ecpp
number about 60. are they the same
number or are they different in what
ways no it's based off the estimated
cost per pupil so the estimated cost and
we're just rounding numbers the
estimated cost per pupil oh it's not on
here is 17 000.
gotcha and then the cap is that right
and we end up with a 60k because it's
3.5 times 17. see that's where I was a
bit confused by and you know I'm new so
I appreciate it and the other club my
original question really was that 98.27
I thought you said earlier that in that
this is a fund where everything gets
paid out and topped off I may again need
a clarification it's it's because
special education Aid we do have a
budget and we can't go over it four or
two uh sorry that's all term court order
students
um it's because of the way it's written
in the law it we keep we can have more
funds added to our budget so the this
court ordered are the ones where the
budget is replenished as needed because
there is you know the statute says there
is no cap we just pay as needed while in
the special education Aid we have a
budget we try to get it right but then
we prorate if we are over it I really
appreciate clarifications thank you
so the next slide just gives you an
overview of special education Aid
history if you look at the far right
column it tells you what percentage we
paid out special education Aid and
before
um 21 and 2020 and 2021 we were
prorating almost every year since 2008.
um we did do 100 for those two years of
2020 and 2021 but then again this past
year we go went back to prorating again
and that's also on this other sheet as
well a little bit larger than what is on
this
it's a lot of numbers so
I think reps
question
Pro rating cat Aid makes a big
difference too small special ed age
sorry
um makes a big difference to little
school districts
um
when our once we pass the budget when
our superintendents notified the rate at
which
or are you able to tell them the rate at
which they'll get reimbursed so I have
to give um the state has to give an
estimated cost so in September the
beginning of September
um oh I think it's due October 1st we
have an estimated cost and that's before
we're we're finishing our review process
so
um it gives them a rough estimate of
what they'll get reimbursed and if we
can reimburse that 100 and we knew in
September we were not going to be able
to reimburse at 100 all right thank you
you have a big job thank you for what
you do it's a real big job right so
through that process they in July they
start to submit their invoices and all
of those pieces for special education
Aid and we go through all of their
documents as compared to the IEP so that
in September end of September she has
that number to be able to put forward
thank you Mr chair uh and uh let me see
2011 we uh we looked at this
and we looked at funding at 100 and we
predicted it was going to be 90 million
dollars which is very close to that
number which is
you know it's kind of interesting uh way
back then it was uh you could see the
trend but we've but we're reducing in
population which
you know but you it's not really it's
reducing faster than uh what was
what 2007
I mean it's it's uh interesting to look
at yeah
um the last page shows you um when we
each year what the estimated cost per
pupil is or that eccp ecpp and what the
three times is and what the ten times
were for all of those years just to give
you an idea of how that is the last one
is just a breakdown of our federal funds
um that I put in if you if you had
questions about it or
just as an informational piece
and as I said on this sheet all of the
pieces that are on this are just here
bigger so that you can see them
and now I was like I can barely read
that thank you
um this is education I guess on a more
philosophical level as opposed to your
numbers
um we often hear of you know parents
will come in to say the school's not
meeting the needs of my child and it
seems like I mean you're going over
backwards there's so much money that is
put towards an individual child how
often do you get that how do you respond
to some of that
it's so it's difficult to respond to
that because of all um decisions are
made for that IEP team meeting so it's
really down to that granular level of
the decision is made based on the child
in the IEP team meeting
um we do not have we're not able to say
no you can't do that because the team
made that decision
um we do have the complaints process
where they can call and they can say I
need assistance with this I don't think
my child is getting what they need but
really it is that IEP team meeting that
you go to to say yes this is what the
needs are this is what we think should
happen
um we do monitor districts through
another office within our Bureau and
they get down we get as granular as we
can and we do as much as we can with our
authority to say you're not you're not
providing these these Services the way
you should be providing them or you're
not providing reports to parents to show
their progress so those are the pieces
that we we try to do on the back end but
really you can't make you can't change
an IEP team's decision about what
happens
um because it is that's the authority
that idea has given them can you tell
the parent yeah we are
many times districts do do that but it's
like I said it's at that District level
that you know District or SAU or it's at
that level so it's difficult for us to
go ahead thank you um how many uh
kids come off about a special ed
and what would you do to incentivize
kids coming off especially because it
would seem so you know if they have a
need
then we Supply that need some kids
should be coming off
I think it would vary District by
District how many kids they're keeping
on and how many kids they're taking off
um if you know you have some districts
where their numbers are very low because
they're very they have a multi-tiered
system of support within their school so
that you can be meeting some of those
needs without placing them in special
education whereas other districts May
any child that needs assistance they may
be identifying them at a higher rate
than another District so it's hard to
say how you would get them to um
not identify the child it really is
based on the progress of the child if
the child has met their goals and
they're you know there's no gap between
where they should be and where they're
where their
um Regular education peers are it would
be hard hard to uh determine
we do not no
I could we I mean we could see how many
students are discharged but that
discharge from special education is also
if they've moved to another District if
a parent has refused if they've
graduated if they've you know there's a
variety of exiting information that that
that includes
On a related question when I was on the
school board in Windham we made a
significant significant investment in
early intervention in the hope of
minimizing the amount of resources that
those students will need based on the
theory that if you come in early you may
be able to do it with more you know with
more Effectiveness and it will decrease
the amount of resources you need later
is this something that you guys are
monitoring or do you have thoughts on on
whether early investments in early
intervention result in a you know
reduction of services needed down the
road or uh you know because right now I
just have anecdotal data I'm looking to
see whether you know the state sees
something in the data across the state
on that so we have a third office within
the bureau the office of special
programs and what they do is they work
with districts around best practices for
improving results for students with
disabilities one of the things that we
sponsor is
Universal Design for Learning for school
districts or udl and Assisting School
Districts and developing that
school-wide so that improves improves
the overall teaching for students to
improve their results to do exactly what
you said to you know get them early and
assist them early so that you're trying
to mitigate that impact of the what they
potentially have as a difficulty
um
we also um we also do I lost my train of
thought no worries so basically just in
general terms that seems to you know my
experience in Windham relates to your
opinion and the best practices best
practices in the state right yeah okay
yeah and the other I I just remembered
so the other piece is we've targeted
reading actually for the young ages we
are doing our state systemic Improvement
plan targeted at reading starting at the
kindergarten level because we feel that
it will be helpful for exactly the
reason that you've said because research
has shown that it's it that that is
helpful so thank you
thank you
um following on the same line some of
these issues are lifelong they're not
going to go away there's not a cure
um
do you have a sense of how many students
are you know have sort of an issue that
is dealable in this way and can
eventually move off of a special ed
individual program as opposed to how
many students will be dealing with these
issues for their life
it's because it's such a varying um I
mean you saw the number of disabilities
that we have because some of those
disabilities vary so much it's hard to
say
um and we're not at that granular level
with the district saying where they are
um disability wise and really we're
trying to ensure that they may have this
disability for the rest of their life
but how did they work with that
disability and how that can they become
successful with the accommodations and
the things that we teach them throughout
their their career
important
I'm all set okay thank you
you're on
nothing back
hello everyone Mark Manganiello with the
Department of Education Office of school
of Finance I see a lot of new faces to
division two nice to meet you welcome to
the division I've been with the
department for two years I actually used
to be an LBA performance auditor so I
was trained by Mike Kane and Mickey
landergan and I worked on this Committee
in the before so it's it's always good
to be back to division two
um like Caitlyn said we're going to be
talking about the different adequacy
programs so in front of you you have a
adequacy spreadsheet for fiscal year 22
for charter school so charter school has
an adequacy program and inadequacy
funding formula there's some
similarities with District adequacy but
we're just going to walk through the
charter school adequacy formula Tyler's
going to talk about some of the
programming pieces and then we're going
to talk about District adequacy
so
when you look at the charter school
adequacy formula that First Column is
the charter school the second column is
ADM ADM is a fancy way to say students
it's the average daily membership and so
we we call it ADM because it's meant to
capture a full school year enrollment so
if um if a student was there for all 180
days of a school year you would say 180m
that is one student but if a student was
there for 90 days at this Charter School
you would do 90 days divided by how many
days in the school year 180 you would
call that 0.580m so we count a student
not just a snapshot count we count their
whole school year and we converted into
something called an ADM but it's
essentially a pupil count for simplistic
terms
so for each ADM in the charter school
formula and this is also true with the
district adequacy formula as well as the
EFA formula there's something called
base adequacy so for 180m
um for fiscal year 22 you get 3
786.66 so if your student is attending a
charter school for a full year that is
your base adequacy amount that you're
you're essentially guaranteed if you
attend the full year
we look at that student and we look at
additional demographic information about
that student so that those components
are called differential Aid so with that
student you've already counted them as
180m if they're half an ADM you'd get
half of the
3786.66 but if we have one student one
ADM you're getting your base adequacy
aid but we look at other demographic
information about that student so if the
student is eligible for we call it f and
R but it's free and reduced price meals
essentially what that means is that
student is below 185 percent of the
federal poverty guideline so if they're
below 185 percent of the federal poverty
guideline we count them as a student
basically as our poverty metric as a
student experiencing poverty and we also
they are eligible for the fnr program
the fnr program is overseen by the food
and nutrition Bureau within the division
of learner support that's a separate
program the one we talk about fnr
numbers
uh free and reduced price meals number
and adequacy we're not talking about a
meals program we're just talking about
identifying a student that is below 185
percent of the federal poverty guideline
so a student experiencing poverty so
it's good to think about those as two
separate programs but they use the same
data sets
so if a charter school student is
identified as being in the fnr eligible
for the f r program we also add not only
the base adequacy but
1893.32 cents this is the fiscal year 22
formula
um into the formula
then I'm going to skip over sped for a
second and move on to English language
learner which is the next column after
that if the student is an English
language learner that's a particular
program that is federally federally
funded federally regulated and state
implemented if they're um an English
language learner I mean they're learning
English essentially we add 740 dollars
and 87 cents uh to the uh adequacy aid
for 180m
um the next one is third grade reader
this is not a lot of students typically
but if the student is in third grade
they scored below proficient on the
third grade reading test and they are
not f r eligible nor are they sped uh
receiving sped Services nor are they an
English language English language
learner then we add
740.87 to the formula
um so we're telling these all up
um sped as the last one sped is kind of
unique because the way sped works is the
a district of responsibility so where
the student lives is their home public
school traditional Public School
District they are the district
responsibility so sped is a little bit
different so you just need to think
about that when you talk about Charter
but just to go back to how sped works if
the student is in a charter school they
are receiving they have an IEP so
they're receiving sped Services we take
one ADM and add two thousand and thirty
seven dollars and 11 cents to the
adequacy formula and so what we're doing
here is we're telling these all up so if
we look at the Academy of Science and
design charter school which is the first
one there we'll do 528 times the base
rate of
3786.66 we get two million dollars there
F and R we're doing the same process 22.
times
1893 and 32 cents and we get 42 000 sped
we're doing the 12 times the 2037 we're
getting 24K English language Learners
we're doing five times the 740 we're
getting 3704 and then they had no uh
third grade readers they might they
might just be high school I don't know
but um they had no uh third grade below
proficient third grade readers that's
also not a very common metric used
um or a number we have so we're telling
this all up and we're getting something
called the cost of an adequate education
so everything I just explained is also
true for district the district formula
it's also true for the EFA formula this
is what we call adequacy adequacy has a
lot of different names sometimes we call
this constitutional adequacy because
when we say the cost of an opportunity
for an adequate education that's a
certain standard the state has the state
has determined that these metrics at
these price rates is a standard that we
must fund our schools so sometimes it's
called constitutional adequacy sometimes
it's called just adequacy sometimes it's
called the left side of the formula when
Mickey talks about a spreadsheet the
spreadsheet might have complicated
things going on in the right side of the
formula but the left side of the formula
it might just be adequacy so it can get
really jargony and difficult to talk
about but if you sit down with Mickey
and work through a formula and a
spreadsheet those are some of the terms
you'll go to become familiar with if you
do that work and study study these
spreadsheets more more deeply
um so we're telling those all up to
become the cost of an adequate education
um so when we sum that up for all the
charters in fiscal year 22 we get 27
million dollars so that's base plus
differential Aid
now Charters had something that's up
above and beyond the cost of an adequate
education it's called an additional
Grant and it's just basically a flat
rate per ADM and so it's for uh fiscal
year 22 it's
3552 and 28 cents and so
I I have the charter school formula uh
printed out here charter schools have an
additional Grant above and beyond the
cost of an adequate education as we talk
about District formula you'll notice
districts also have additional grants
they have different names and we'll
we'll talk a little bit about those the
different District formula when we get
there but the charters formula uh Aid
above and beyond the cost of an adequate
education is called additional Grant
districts have their own additional
grants but they have different names
which will make more sense when we do
that presentation
so telling that all up we get uh 46
million dollars for 46.7 million dollars
in the adequacy formula the only thing
that's different with Charters is we
send that 46 million dollars we don't
send all 46 million dollars to Charter
Schools we send them 45 million dollars
because the 1.4 million in sped adequacy
goes to the district school and so
because the district is financially
responsible for for doing the sped
Services
um or for paying for this bad Services
um and they work come up with agreements
with the charter schools to figure out
how that's going to work how the service
delivery is going to work and how it's
going to be funded or built
um
so that's the the charter school formula
um do we have any questions about the
charter school formula
right thank you
chair thank you for taking my question
uh first of all ADM no is that
enrollment basically
it's yeah it's so enrollment sometimes
in uh and then this is a jargon
technical thing sometimes enrollment
means snapshot I use it universally but
sometimes when you see enrollment it
could mean snapshot meaning One Moment
In Time another way to talk about it is
membership but but yes it's essentially
enrollment well now you mentioned half
of an ADM how do you come up with that
okay so we we look at a calendar
um so if a calendar is 180 days we
actually do it to the half day so we do
a calendar of 360 half days but just to
make it easy we'll just say 180 days
because that's a typical school year so
we are looking a student sends us
information of when the student came
into the school so if the first day of
school is September 1st we start
counting each day and we have their
calendar so we know the holidays we know
that teacher conference days whatever
whatever there's an instructional day
that is their calendar they must provide
that 180 instructional days there's also
it gets complicated there's also hours
but just to keep the math easy we'll use
180 days some people provide more than
180 days but just keep them easy we know
if the first day of school is September
1st and the last day of school June 15th
and in between they they have a bunch of
holidays whatever it may be we know it
tallies up to 180 days because we've
done the math
um we'll track the students attendance
throughout the year and if the student
leaves the school we'll say okay they
left on
let's say December 31st and if we if we
look at their calendar we know you've
been credited 90 days if the math works
out that way we know you've been
credited 98 days if you have provided
you have been responsible for 90 days of
instructional days for this student then
we do 90 days divided by the full
calendar which is 180 which would equal
the 0.5 ATM okay one final question if I
may uh so you're not counting the days
that he's absent that's a good question
representative
um it's all about yeah we don't we don't
look at attendance so if the student
misses a day goes is sick we're not
docking your adequacy it is where the
student is enrolled it needs to be a
member
um is the student might show up might
not show up they might be tardy as long
as that district is so just to back up a
little bit every child and I don't know
the age is a sick basically 6 to 18 is
compulsory attendance I think every
student needs to be in an educational
pathway the most popular of those
educational Pathways is the district
public school system so the student will
sign up with their District Public
School System saying I am a student in
this system
um uh and so they're they're
communicating to the district that they
they that they're you know they're in
that school system they're going to show
up and we will fund them as if they
would show it up every day essentially
right thank you one final question that
just came up uh in my mind here uh
homeschoolers some attend just some
classes how do you handle that
that's a good question
um so if a student tells their District
that they are homeschooled that means um
there's a particular enrollment status
that we capture in our system they are
home educated they are not
a student of their District they're not
going to likely get a degree from
they're not going to get a degree from
their District they're going to get a
home education program they're going to
graduate through the home education
program
um I can't go into the details about how
that exactly works but they are
home educated the district is aware of
them they can attend courses because
they are taxpayers
um basically the way the policy works is
they do pay local taxes so they're
entitled to extracurricular activities
if they want to join the sports team
they can do that if they want to take a
course they can do that the state never
sorry the state only reimburses for
homeschool kids taking courses if
there's additional Appropriations in the
adequacy line item so that is how
current law works there's a couple bills
in House Ed if they make it through
House Ed to the house floor into Finance
you might see those bills there's bills
to
waive the conditional requirement that
we only reimburse districts for
educating homeschool students on a
course by force basis if there's
additional Appropriations so there is
bills in the house education to remove
that conditional requirement that
there's excess Appropriations
um but there yeah we have about the
equivalent of 36 students that are home
educated taking coursework at districts
thank you
um
sorry representative Heath oh I know my
question just went out oh I know what I
want to ask you to do would you explain
um adequacy is paid out to public school
districts differently than adequacy
payments are paid out to Public School
uh to public charters
is it still the same where they're paid
um oh oh yeah
um yeah there's a different distribution
schedule that's right um just to clarify
I'll talk about the distribution
schedule um when I say 38 students um
it's actually 300 students but if we
roll up their coursework to be the
equivalent of a full-time student and it
would equal like 38 full-time students
just to clarify that but that's right
representative Heath uh so the charter
distribution schedule is we do a first
day count and we pay 30 of what we think
the full payment would be so you get a
first day count we calculate well we
think the full annualized payment will
be and we pay 30 in September
um then we pay another 30 percent in
November
oh no December now I'm going to mess the
schedule up
um and then another 30 percent in March
um 30 of what we think the total amount
will be and then we do a 10 after the
school year is complete we have a full
capture of all the charter school data
and we pay that last 10 percent and um
we have to do that uh with Charters we
have to do that 10 correction
um pretty quick turnaround because with
Charters we're paying them in the same
year that the charter student was
educated we're paying them in that same
year so that's different with Charter
Schools with district schools we have a
one-year lack so
um whatever the student was in school
year 22 whatever the ADM was in 22 we
pay you in 23. whatever the ADM is in
this year we'll pay you in 24.
so there's a one-year lag on District
data suite and the distribution schedule
is different the distribution for
adequacy is 20 in September uh 20 to
November and then 30 percent
um in uh January then 30 percent uh and
then approximately 30 whatever the uh if
there needs to be any reconciliation but
30 in April
I just wanted to follow up on one of
your comments earlier when we were
talking about the differential Aid
um you mentioned that I the third grade
non-proficient reading score was
exclusive from the other differentials
so you know if a student had already
qualified for federal free and reduced
or sped or English Learners then they
wouldn't qualify as a third grade
differential that's correct so my
question I guess leading back to that is
um are the other three differentials
also exclusive of 30 no so it's only
third grade is exclusive okay thank you
correct
shout out adequate questions I'll bring
towel up he'll talk about uh programming
with Charter Schools
can y'all hear me now
uh it's tal t-a-l Bayer b-a-y-e-r just
like bare aspirin
I believe you all have this handout so I
just wanted to take a moment I'm not
sure what um some of your sort of
familiarity with Charter Schools are so
I was gonna do sort of a brief talk
about them and then kind of work into
more financial related information first
off uh charter schools are public
tuition free
um schools that are authorized by RSA
here in the state of New Hampshire
um that authorization initially occurred
in 1995 the first Charter School opened
in 2005. as of this year we now have 30
charter schools in the state of New
Hampshire serving approximately 4 900
students
in brick and mortar charter schools and
then there's an additional
619 in velax full-time and then there's
full-time equivalent where they're
taking a couple classes here and a
couple classes there and if you add all
those up there's an approximately
additional 1350 students full-time
equivalents that are also in vlac
um if you were to look at the enrollment
Trends
um you can see the graph here to the
side but essentially 2010 is the
smallest block there's gradual increases
from 10 15 to 20.
um this year it's about a 14 increase
from last year
um not surprising considering sort of
the pandemic and its impacts on student
education
if we flip the page over
um this is just kind of kind of a brief
synopsis of how these schools break down
um
there are very few charter schools that
are larger typically than about
um 200 students a majority of charter
schools are in the 100 to 199 or less
than 100 student range there are the
mega schools there are two schools that
are serving between five and six hundred
students but again majority of schools
tend to be on that smaller side
um
flipping into a little more Finance
Focus for those that aren't familiar
there is What's called the CSP Federal
grant it's a grant by the federal
government it's the charter school
program Grant which essentially helps
allows AIDS charter schools and starting
up during that critical time when
funding resources are not readily
available the grant is a 46 million
dollar Grant
um currently and I'll give you a kind of
the breakdown of it but of that 46
million dollar Grant 90 go to sub
grantees sub-grantees are prospective
Charter Schools seven percent would then
go to technical assistance and support
for these schools excuse me
and then the remaining three percent is
for Administration staff to kind of
oversee monitor
um both the Grant and support the
charter schools if you were to look at
this grant to date over 17 million has
been obligated out to sub-grantees
um we have roughly a million in uh
technical assistance contracts approved
by GNC and these contracts are for
things for PD support of the charter
school community and then the
administrative costs right now we're
running at about 3.8 percent over the
remaining life of the grant that will
drop down below the three percent it's
just as we initially started there was a
lot more sort of administrative startup
to get the the grant established but
it'll even out below that three percent
mark
um
subgrant overview
grants are awarded to some grantees
through a competitive process to date
we've held two Grant competitions we're
actually in the middle of our third as
we speak which um we will be closing out
that competition in early March
um of the sub Awards as mentioned 17
million have been doled out 11 went to
New charter schools and then five went
to existing schools what can this money
be used for essentially you have two
phases in a charter school with opening
you have what's called
um
uh startup or planning phase which can
last up to 18 months it could be
anything uh funding could be used for
anything from curriculum design and
preparation purchase of materials for
the School Technology if you have a
design person or a program administrator
or director of school who is overseeing
the the build out of the school you
could be paying their salary through
that community outreach marketing
website design it's pretty open to a
very broad array of costs associated
with starting the school and then once
the school opens it its doors this grant
becomes highly restrictive and it moves
into what's called implementation phase
you can no longer pay salaries you
you're essentially limited to things
like
um
uh equipment marketing Outreach
professional development
training it becomes much more restricted
in Focus because the understanding is at
this point the schools should be
um
uh not self-funded but operational based
off of support from from state aid
the last page is just a breakdown of
Mark has done quite a bit of talking
about ADM it's individual breakdowns of
schools and their average ADM
we we mentioned the the four thousand if
you look in the far right corner the
4900 students in charter schools that
that's the total of all these schools up
above
um so happy to answer any questions you
all might have
since we don't have the color can you
confirm on the page before 69 is startup
25 expansion six replication absolutely
yes um so the smallest slice would be
replication the largest is startup with
25 for the expansion
um and just to provide a little bit of
context for that with the the
replications it is always a challenge uh
encouraging getting Charters to
replicate because they're so con sort of
consumed with their own existence
um and that is actually one of our our
challenges right now in terms of
pipeline building is getting high
quality schools to replicate
okay just didn't think Mr chair just a
quick clarification question on page two
I wondered whether it's the table or the
graph that has the accurate numbers
because there are two discrepancies
between the numbers listed on the left
and the bars on the right
generally I assume it's the table that's
correct
you know it says that you know the graph
says that five schools are in the 200 to
299 while the table says four and there
is no school in the 400 499 on the table
but there is one in sorry there is one
in the table and none in the graph I
need to check that I didn't catch that
error if you could just clarify which
are the accurate ones you know it's not
a huge deal but every little detail May
matter it's an important deal so I'd
like to get that information corrected
thank you
I've got a question on this 46 million
dollars is that
every year or one-time Grant or
so it it the total Grant is 46 million
dollars
um and it's over the life of the the
grant so I I it officially would end uh
next year uh and then we would get no
cost extensions to kind of oversee the
the grantees through their their
expensive funds but it's not 46 each
year it's a 46 million dollars total as
long as it lasts or until it expires
exactly yeah how much do you have left
uh well to again obligated to date has
been what did that number I gave you was
17 million
um so we're not really too worried about
you're not running out of money right
yeah okay one of the the challenges
we're facing so if you don't know the
history of the Grant had been delayed
for a little while when it finally got
implemented it's been a a bit of
catch-up trying to expend funds and then
additionally
um
encouraging schools to spend and utilize
the money so it uh I think it it is
certainly uh sped up as we've uh
implemented the program
um but when we first started it took
almost six months to get folks to start
using money and I think a lot of that
was more connected with
schools were flush with PPP funds Esser
funds a variety of
easier access and easier to to document
funding sources okay thank you yes
thank you Mr chair one of the things
when Charters first came into being was
that they'd be
um coordination with the traditional
public school districts in terms of
sharing
excellent ideas or model programs like
in for instance Manchester we have the
wonderful Mills Falls charter school
it's a Montessori school and it's
absolutely exceptional
um always wishing that there be some
kind of a pathway or maybe incentive for
some of the cool things that we've seen
in Charters to be learned or brought
into our public school system that has
never come to pass
I wouldn't use the term never come to
pass it is taken longer than it should
um I will tell you so I I moved here
from Washington DC and we kind of ran
into a similar problem when we opened
the first charter school I worked with
it was 99. um it took almost 15 years
until the the wall between public and
Charter came down a bit it's a lot of
trust building partnership building
capacity building between schools
schools like Mills Falls
um reaching beyond their walls and then
Public Schools receiving that
communication I guess it's happening but
it is a slow process and then also
finding opportunities for both public
and Charters to operate in shared space
so for example there's a monthly you
know State superintendent calls used to
be Charter Schools weren't part of that
now they are so that's a shared space
that helps create that environment one
of the other things that we're also
doing through this grant is one of the
objectives is to create that sort of
shared Community
we are hosting both conferences as well
as PD days where we'll be inviting both
public and Charters and then within
those conferences trying to create some
icebreaking activities just to get folks
to to connect
yes breed I'm really really happy to
hear that
um I have had a couple of concerned
parents call me in terms of questioning
why that
um a charter may be advertising that
they are following a certain Christian
curriculum is that I explained that
that's not possible that that they are
public schools so they are not sectarian
in nature
absolutely
um I I'd be curious if if you have names
of those schools I'd love to see that
because within their Charter we review
those at time of Charter approval if
there were language in there indicating
anything of that nature it would be
immediately addressed and if after
approval they were doing that I would
encourage any parent to bring that to
our attention all right thank you yep
yep appreciate it thank you
foreign
so are you saying that's the biggest
they have
or enough
oh my God that's fine
foreign
there's a lot of school funding and this
is mostly District school funding that
we're going to be covering here it's a
big topic
um some people on this committee have
been studying it for years some people
are new to it some people have dabbled
in it
um even for veterans it can be a
difficult sometimes non-intuitive
process to study all the ins and outs
there's complexities to it we're going
to try to talk through some of those if
you kind of hit a brick wall and you're
struggling with something don't be
discouraged you can talk to the
department you can talk to the LBA and
we can help you work through some of the
nuances of school funding
um
and there's a lot of information in here
some of it's more of a reference some of
it I'll be talking through today uh
so the first handout is 22 Pages if you
go to page two
this is a
summary of all revenues and expenditures
for all district public schools and so I
always start a training with this
document because really it shows you the
size and scope of our district public
schools and so there's how much money is
spent how much money including local
state and federal dollars is spent on
District Public Schools the number is uh
in fiscal year 22 how much revenue did
they get is 3.6 billion so to put that
in context uh kind of fun fact is our
New Hampshire economy is 80 billion
dollars so District Public Schools
represent about four percent of the New
Hampshire economy so that's sort of just
interesting to put into context about
how the size and scope of of this policy
area that is the sort of policy or of
education but also shared with um
division two
um so when we're talking to districts we
like to tell districts you should know
how you get your money
um so when we look at that 3.5 3.6
billion dollar Revenue number right here
um we have percentage breaks down of
where that money is coming so the
largest funder of schools is the local
education property tax so that is 2.2
billion dollars and it makes about on
average 60 percent of the funding mix of
District Public Schools so that is the
the biggest funder of school is local
education property taxes
I have a couple documents here to talk
about the Statewide education property
tax so just to back up a little bit
property taxpayers the typical property
taxpayer pays four taxes they pay a
municipal tax they pay a county tax so
the municipal tax is mostly covering
fire police power agent you name it uh
County taxes covering our County
Services
local education property tax that's
funding our local schools these are all
local taxes then we have a Statewide
education property tax that is also
funding our Public Schools but it is a
state tax and so it can trip people up
and we'll have a few documents to go
through the difference between a local
education and a Statewide education
property tax and how how that Statewide
education one works and we have a tax
cut that's effective this year that I'm
going to walk you through
so going back to this document
um about 60 percent of funding is coming
from local education that is the local
education property tax it does not
include swept the next biggest funding
source is adequacy Aid so that makes up
on average 27 percent of the funding mix
of District Public Schools
um and that is the line item of adequacy
that and does include the Statewide
education property tax and we'll go and
we'll explain that in further detail
later
um the only thing other interesting
thing I'd like to point out is we've had
a lot of federal money coming into
schools so we had three covid stimulus
bills they all have acronyms those
acronyms have acronyms so we have cares
act Carissa
ARP the way we talk about them in this
in school funding is their the acronyms
beneath those are sr1 sr2 sr3 so what
you need to know is that about 650
million dollars in federal funding um
due to covid
um went to District public schools and
as you can see about half of that money
or so has already been shown up in their
fiscal year 22 financials so if you look
at their funding mix in 2020 Federal
funding was 4.8 percent of their funding
mix so a very tiny amount now it's up to
8.9 percent of their Federal funding mix
or their school funding mix so um it's
growing in size but relative to local
property taxes and relative to State
funding it is still a relatively small
number
but that is how the federal funding has
a quick
drawing down the funds the federal funds
in a timely manner
it's a lot of money
I knew you'd have something thank you
yep we have a dashboard I mean I only
have uh once the fiscal year is closed I
get the financial data from the
districts but we do have real-time data
from our grants management system but
um so far so good we don't know where
they'll well they'll end up when the the
money runs out or in the period of
performance runs out hopefully they're
able to spend it all but yeah there was
a slow start which you remember from the
beginning there's this little start but
they've picked up from now
so moving on to uh page three
page three is a way to think about uh
some of the programs that are funded
through the education trust fund a lot
of these programs we've talked about
today
um you you got the top there you have
sped Aid so you had the sped Bureau come
in and talk about sped Aid that's paid
out of the education trust fund there's
multiple other programs in here I'm not
going to go into detail but I will point
out that the largest of the programs is
adequacy adequacy makes up about 90 to
95 percent
of all uh State funding districts
receive so adequacy is the largest state
funding source although there are lots
of programs
so if we go to page four
this is a pie graph
of the education trust fund Revenue as
recorded in the annual comprehensive
financial report for fiscal year 22.
so like I said most of the education
state aid programs that go to schools
come from the education trust fund will
the education trust fund is a fund that
receives a bunch of different Revenue
sources so if you look at the table
there the the biggest Revenue sources
are really business taxes well swept is
the biggest but the biggest non-swept
source is uh business taxes so 177
million in business profits 297 in
business Enterprise
there's a bunch of other taxes there you
might notice Lottery has
146 million dollars so you've probably
you probably when you if you buy a
scratch ticket or a lottery ticket it
says that goes to the Department of
Education to fund education that's what
we're talking about um I know lotteries
also within this division
um The Lottery Commission the way it
works is they run their business they
play they run their games and whatever
profit they have over gets transferred
to the education trust fund and so they
bring in 146 million dollars
so I get questions from citizens I'm
sure you get it as well
um some people go well I thought Lottery
was going to pay for all of Education
well it pays for 146 million and we're
very grateful that they're able to
provide that but it does not pay for the
full you know 3.6 billion in Revenue
that they that they need
um so uh this is just all the different
programs that go into the education all
the different Revenue sources that go
into the education trust fund
um the biggest one on there is the swept
and the swept we're gonna spend a lot of
time talking about the swept because it
can be a little complicated so the swept
is a Statewide education property tax
and it taxes all property taxpayers
except for utilities if you notice on
this table utilities have their own
property tax so they're excluded from
the swept
but the way to think about the swept is
the state sets a number and Statute in
which it wants to raise so the number in
statute or they said it would be a
chapter law but the number on staff
statute is 363 million dollars so for
fiscal year 22 the state wanted to raise
363 million dollars and so then they
look at the full tax base of the swept
how much property values exist in the
state and so in fiscal year 22 the total
sum of property value was 200 billion
dollars
so if you do 363 million over 200
billion you get and then you multiply
that number by a thousand you get a mill
rate a tax rate of 1.83 per thousand so
that was the swept tax rate in fiscal
year 22 on an equalized basis we can get
into different how taxes actually
affects our tax bill can be a little
technical but on an equalized basis
essentially the tax rate was 1.83.
and fiscal year 23 there was a one-time
swept tax cut so where via chapter law
in hb2 and the 2223 budget the law was
changed to say the swept will not be 363
million it will be 263 million so 100
million less and it and we did uh dra
when calculating that they did 263
million over 213 billion so property
values had grown and they got a mill
rate of a dollar twenty three per
thousand so essentially the swept tax
cut was approximately because property
values went up the tax tax really went
down but essentially that tax cut was a
50 cents per thousand tax cut that is in
effect in this current tax year the tax
bill that you're that we're um that
you're paying taxes on if you pay
property taxes so that is
um how the swept tax cut works
um but it's more complicated than that
um
it's um the way swept works is kind of
unique in a sense that if I go over to
uh well I'll explain it in further
detail later I have a lot of handouts on
it but swept is fully retained locally
so essentially the the tax collector in
your community gets the gets the levy
that they must raise from the dra so if
they have to raise a hundred thousand
dollars they'll make sure that they send
out tax bills to raise a hundred
thousand dollars and swept but they have
to raise that money and they have to
give it all to their school district
they can't keep any of it so they raise
that money they give it to their school
district and so all of these Financial
transactions that are occurring are all
recorded um uh they're recorded on the
state ledger so a community is
collecting taxes and a community sending
attacks to their school district but no
money actually comes into a stake bank
account but when you read their kafer
and you read the financial documents and
you look at the budget we record that as
if the revenue came into the state and
we do that because we mandated it via
law that the revenue must be raised and
then we mandated via law that the
revenue must be spent meaning it must go
to the school district so we record that
363 million as coming into the state
even though no literal dollar came into
the state we just know it happened
um
and then we record all of it going to
the school district as an expenditure so
when you think about swept it gets a
little complicated you have to think
about the local ledgers and the state
ledgers and I have a few documents to go
through that and uh we might have
questions but um I'll go forward and
talk about the adequacy formula and talk
about how that swept cut interacts with
the adequacy formula which adds another
layer of complexity
so on page five this is the adequacy
formula so some of it's going to sound
familiar to the district formula so this
is fiscal year 23. in this formula it
changes pretty much every year for the
past five years it has changed every
year so it's hard to keep track of it
some things stay the same
but there's always tinkering with it and
tweaks to it so
fiscal year 23 and 24 no different so
just going through the adequacy formula
a similar process we are calculating the
average daily membership
um so same process if you're 180 day
school year you're there for 90 days
that's 0.5 ATM same same calculation
essentially it's a little different with
Charters and districts but um for for
this discussion it's basically an ADM uh
is remember looking at enrollment
through a full year
um oh in this formula uh we call it
pupil I say pupil count because that's
how the lva labeled it once
um
so sorry yeah ADM it's different this is
a different uh document it's not it's
not spreadsheet with ADM but it's the
same process so if you have 180m in a
district you get a base Aid of 3786.66
yep sorry about that um so yeah the
first line is base adequacy Aid so we're
looking at your 180m is
3786.66 just like it is for Charter
Schools
um and we're going through the same
process just like Charter Schools we're
also going to look for additional
demographic information so just like
Charter Schools we're gonna look to see
if that student is fnr eligible if they
are fnr eligible meaning they are 185
percent below the federal poverty
guideline we are adding 1
000 uh uh
1893.32 cents
if they are receiving sped Services same
as Charter Schools uh we add two
thousand thirty seven dollars and 11
cents
um if that student is also an English
language learner we are adding 740 and
87 cents
and then if the student is a third grade
reader um meaning it's the the exclusive
exclusive uh metric there if they are in
third grade
scored below proficient third grade
reading test and they're not fnr not
sped or not English language learner
then we add in
740.87 and so just like Charter Schools
this is just a funding formula this is
unrestricted Aid to districts this is
not restricted to the fnr program at a
district this is not restricted to the
sped program at a district this is not
restricted to the English language
learner program at a at a district this
is just a measurement a way to calculate
the cost of an adequate education just
like Charters
um but after that it starts to get
different than Charters so we're telling
up all these metrics so if you have a
hundred students in your school we would
do a hundred times the
3786.66 that would get you your base
adequacy Aid if a hundred of those
students were also fnr eligible we would
do uh sorry if 50 of those 100 students
let's say we're fnr eligible We Do 50
times
1893 and 32 cents
if 20 of them were sped eligible same
metric we take the 20 times uh two
thousand and thirty seven dollars and 11
cents and then if you know same process
goes on we're telling up all those
students and we're applying those rate
amounts and so we're telling that all up
to get to the cost of an adequate
education for a district public school
which is the same process for a charter
school so over here we have we tally all
those up
and we get to the cost of an adequate
education
so if we tally up all those metrics and
the cost of an adequate education is a
million dollars we know constitutionally
speaking we have to make sure because
the state has defined this as the
Constitutional adequate education we
need to make sure your district has a
million dollars so instead of we don't
just cut a check right away for a
million dollars we check to see how much
money did you raise through the
Statewide education property tax so if
you raised a million dollars through the
Statewide education property tax
we'd give you a check for zero dollars
um if you raised five hundred thousand
dollars uh through the Statewide
education property tax but your
constitutional adequacy we needed to
fund you at a million dollars you have a
benchmark that you must receive a
million dollars but your swept is only
500 000 so now the state is going to cut
you a check for five hundred thousand
dollars so you're up here so you have at
least a million dollars five hundred
thousand dollars from the state five
hundred thousand dollars from the state
but through the swept
um it's actually collected through your
local tax collector but we call it as it
is a state tax and we call it a state
Grant and we we have them recorded on
their financials as such although uh it
basically never came into the state um
so it's it's sometimes uh it can get
kind of humorous because the districts
go thanks thanks for giving my money
back to me we're like you're welcome
um so that is State policy
um so that is how most districts about
um most districts it follows uh about 95
percent of districts their cost of an
adequate education is uh greater than
what they race through their swept and
so therefore we must cut them a check
but there are some districts or some
municipalities uh adequacies calculate
the municipal level there's some
municipalities where their swept could
be two million dollars and their cost of
inadequate education is a million
dollars and so some people call these
donor towns there's no such thing as
donor towns under current law there was
a process a year ago where if your cost
of inadequate education was a million
dollars and your swept was two million
dollars the state would say you only
needed a million dollars now take two
million take that one million and keep
it and take the other million and send
it to the state and that would go into
the education trust fund and the state
could
do what it wanted with that money and so
those communities said that was a
donation to the state and we are donor
towns that's not that's not the policy
of the state and hasn't been the policy
of the state for 10 years so now
currently if you have a cost of an
adequate education of a million dollars
your swept is two million dollars
you just keep your swept of two million
dollars nothing goes to the state
um this web never goes to the state so
it would go from your tax collector to
your school district and they would have
um uh above and beyond the
Constitutional adequate education they
would have something we call excess
swept but if you hear donor towns there
might be a bill to introduce donor towns
um but under current law there is no
such thing as donor towns and when we're
talking about donor towns that's what
we're talking about is excess swept
coming to the state
so
um moving forward like we talked about
that Community which is most communities
cost of an adequate education is a
million swept is 500 000. we have to cut
you a check for 500 000 that's most
communities they need a check cut from
the state to fully fund them
um there's additional grants after above
and beyond the cost of inadequate
education so one of those grants is
relief Aid relief Aid is what we do is
we look at your fnr your poverty
accounts for each community and we tally
the percent of your community that's f r
students and so if you have a fnr
percentage in your community above 12
percent will give you a hundred and
fifty dollars per each f r student
and then
um if you're if your community is
greater than 40 48 poverty or 40 F and R
we give you a grant of 600 for each fnr
student and then if you're between 12
and between 48 it's a sliding scale so
there's no sort of fiscal cliffs it's
smoothed
um so you'll get a grant between 150 per
F and our student or 600 per F in our
student if you're in between
very brief clarifying questions uh
communities that are under 12 percent
get nothing from this particular Grant
that's correct thank you
um so the relief aid grant also has a a
proration factor so we do that
calculation Statewide and whatever the
number is we prorate up or down to 17.5
million so we could calculate it and it
could be 19 million and we'll bring
everyone down so that the Statewide
total is 17.5 million we could calculate
at Statewide it could be 15 million and
we'll bring everyone up so that it's up
to 17.5 million and there's a bill in
the house that might end up over here to
change that process and policy so we'll
have that conversation
um if that bill makes its way over here
um that's the relief aid grant so
communities with uh fnr percentage above
12 are eligible
um that Grant's been in existence since
fiscal year 22.
extraordinary needs Grant is a new Grant
added in fiscal year 23 this current
fiscal year and the way that Grant works
is it's your property value your
equalized valuations which is the
property value of each Community divided
by your fnr accounts so it's property
value divided by fnr counts and the way
to think about that is this comes up
with a metric the metric is EV FRP it's
it's equalized valuation over F and our
students so it's this it comes up with
this metric and the way to think about
that metric is if you have a lot of
property value and not a lot of f r
students you're going to get a high
number you're going to get a number in
the millions because you probably have a
lot of property value and not a lot of f
in our students you're going to get a
very high number
if you have low property value and a lot
of f r students you're going to get a
very low number so the way this metagram
works is first we calculate your
equalized valuation over your fnr
students to determine if it's basically
it shows you if your community has a mix
of low property values and high poverty
counts in your students it comes up with
a metric if that metric is 6 million
or greater meaning you have kind of
means you kind of have high property
values or low F in our students you do
not get the grant
if it is 1 million or under you get 650
dollars for each fnr student
and then if it's between 1 million to
six million it's a sliding scale Grant
so there's no fiscal cliffs you get a
grant between zero dollars to six
hundred and fifty dollars and that Grant
started in 23 it also comes with an
accountability plan districts have to
complete an accountability plan
um
in order to receive that Grant and
there's there's a bill in house said
um to modify some of those
accountability plans uh requirements
that's a new we just went through our
first process of doing that so again if
that bill comes over here we'll have a
conversation about accountability plans
uh before I go into the swept hold
harmless I'll talk about stabilization
grants so some of you might have heard
about stabilization grants so in fiscal
year 2011 uh or during the um they're
into this 2011 session there were
changes to the school funding formula
this is mostly due to the recession
there was a lot going on in 2011 there
was a huge but Mike Kane can tell you
all about it um the history of it
um but there was changes to the school
funding formula that resulted in schools
districts receiving less money in 2012
than they did in 2011. and in order to
hold those school districts harmless
there was a stabilization grant that
went into place and this is 2012 so this
is 11 years ago
um
and what they set the stabilization
Grant was in 2012 if you receive any
money in the 2012 Formula that is less
than what you received in 2011 we will
give you a stabilization Grant to hold
you up to at a minimum what you received
in 2011. and so when we tallied that
Statewide and fiscally and back in 2012
fiscal year 2012 it turned out to be 158
million dollars so that is the
stabilization grant that held districts
harmless in 2012 to what they received
in 2011. so some communities are still
receiving that a grant because they were
they had to be held harmless in 2012 and
so they're still eligible to receive a
stabilization Grant based on that
calculation that was made in 2012. so
that's when we've talked about
stabilization Grant that's what we're
talking about the eligibility is based
on if you are eligible back in 2012.
um there's also some other details to it
but generally that's what it means
so that's the stabilization Grant uh
there's a there's some history there and
we'll talk a little bit about that
um
thank you uh okay this stabilization
Grant okay if you want this is per pupil
no uh the stabilization Grant and that's
and there's a lot of um some people
think stabilization Grant is tied to
pupil metrics they're it's tied to some
sort of metric the only thing it's tied
to is did you or did you not receive a
stabilization Grant in 2012
really because it if if you look at that
you know you could lose population let's
say a school on another town left your
District
that would you still get the money
uh you if you could have you you could
have declining enrollments you could
have increased enrollment it's a flat
it's a flat number
um based on what you received back in
2012.
so now talking about the swept hold
harmless Grant
um the swept hold harmless Grant deals
with the swept tax cut so when we talk
about that swept tax cut let's go back
to the cost of an adequate education and
how it interacts with swept so if you're
if your cost of an adequate education is
a million and your swept is five hundred
thousand dollars the state has to pay
you a check for 500 000 to bring you up
to the hole
now if we reduce swept so say the swept
for this community was 500 000 but if we
reduce swept across the board let's say
by half let's say the swept is 250 000
well we still need to pay you a million
dollars so you have a constitutionally
adequate amount of funding
um so now the state instead of cutting
your check for 500 000 needs to cut you
a check for 750 000. so naturally when
you cut swept
the swept liability for your taxpayers
decreases and the state still needs to
fund you a constitutionally adequate
education so the state
check increases so that's naturally how
the tax cut works for a lot of
communities about 95 I mean most of the
communities
um
but there's some communities let's talk
about the excess web Community the XX
web Community has a million dollar cost
of an adequate education and a two
million dollar swept now if we cut and
they get to keep two million dollars in
their swept if we cut their swept let's
say by 500 000 so it's 1.5 million
then they only keep 1.5 million so that
means their school district did have two
million dollars now they only have 1.5
million dollars so they have two options
they can either
um raise local property taxes to bring
in an extra five hundred thousand
dollars they could find another Revenue
Source if available
um or they could cut their budget
because they're to to keep taxes equal
they could cut their budget
so there's something called the swept
hold harmless Grant which brings you up
to
um for this particular Community cost of
an adequate education is a million swept
was 2 million now it's down to 1.5
million we give them five hundred
thousand dollars so that their swept is
back to what it was to that two million
number and that 500 000 check is called
the swept hold harmless Grant so that is
uh that is the swept hold harmless Grant
it only exists in fiscal year 23 because
fiscal year 23 is the only year in which
we have a swept tax cut
no uh
yes yes
now and this is done before the school
districts get their hands on it
um in other words when they set the tax
rate
sort of yes yes and so that or it I'm
not going to go into the ins and outs of
tax year versus fiscal year but um the
way we make them record when they may we
make them financially record it we do it
all at once but actually the way the
cash flows through their taxpayers
um there's staggers and delays
but that's right they might be getting a
check um quicker than they would have
normally got it
um there might be some cash flow issues
there yeah
any other questions
sorry I should wave
thank you Mr chairman
um I wanted to go back to the
stabilization Grant
um explainer you just gave us I'm having
a little bit of trouble understanding
uh the concept and I guess my two
questions are was that stabilization
Grant paid over time and is it paid into
perpetuity or is this it was a one-time
deal back in 2012 and it's not
continuing today I guess I'm having a
hard time nope it's continuing today
um there's a history with stabilization
but it's it's it's 158 million
allocation approximately
um if you become an excess swept town
you don't get stabilization anymore
um so it's not actually always 158
million it fluctuates around 157 million
um so that 157 158 million goes out
every year now there was uh changes in
the law
now I can't I gotta have to look at my
other spreadsheet to look at when they
went into effect but there was a law uh
that was enacted I believe in 2015 to
make it phase out by a four percent cut
over 25 years so the stabilization would
go away after 25 years
um and that law took effect and the
stabilization Grant got down to I
believe 88 and then it was fully
restored back to a hundred percent so it
got back it got down to I'll talk at the
other sheet I think maybe 130 million
from the 158 million but now it's back
up to its full full amount from 2012.
how many districts received that
I don't know if this helped my head but
that's uh I think a hundred like no
missing municipality now I'm trying to
think there's probably a number at the
bottom of my spreadsheet but I don't
have it off the top of my head just how
about as a percentage of communities or
I mean it's it's I think it's
I think it's 180 out of 244 towns I
think that's might be I think that's
what I remember that's why I got voted
back in okay
we might not have the district number
but we definitely have the municipal
number
so
I have I have a lot of documents here
they're very wordy so I'm probably I'm
probably going to skip over it a little
bit
um
uh
shoot for two o'clock okay
um this is just explaining that you can
read up on this this is just explaining
in more detail how the swept tax cut
Works
um
I'll show I'll I think it's I'll just go
over this at a high level you can read
this document on your own time
um but
when you think about swept kind of
Representative Buco was laughing a
little bit about the the concept of
swept and how it's a state money versus
local money it's it's it's that's not a
that's not an uncommon opinion um or an
uncon uncommon uh uh perspective so
there's lots of different ways you can
look at a uh us the swept you know you
can look at it from the state's
perspective in a sense that we set the
swept
um we tell you we let you keep it that
the act of us letting you keep it means
it's really uh you know it's our money
we let you keep it
um but there's a lot of different
perspectives of the swept the local
taxpayer
um they kind of view it just as part of
their total tax rate and they really
can't tell the difference between if a
swept is a local education money or a
state education money and so I've been
talking to supers lately
um
they're working on their fiscal year 24
budgets and there's nothing they can do
a deliberative session that is going to
change the swept so the tax rates the
swept tax increase is going to go up in
fiscal year 24. and so they can
communicate to their taxpayers that the
swept tax is going up but there's
nothing they can do a deliberative
session to control the Statewide
education property tax they can make
moves in deliberative session that could
impact the local education tax
um
but it truly is a state tax in a sense
that locally they have no control over
it it is set through state law it is set
through State policy what the swept is
going to be so there's a lot of
different perspectives and and from a
taxpayers perspective they can get
frustrated
um uh of course and uh and school
districts can get confused um sometimes
the swept money comes in the same way it
comes in with their local education tax
money and they don't even know the
difference but I tell them they have to
record them differently and they go okay
well you know what what's the number
coming in I'm like this is the numbers
that this is you're getting a local Ed
money from your school from your
municipality you're also getting the
swept money so it creates some some
complexities for sure
um and it's basically based on
perspective and how you feel about the
swept
um
the the last thing is just sort of a
walk through on how the swept tax cut
works from a fiscal no perspective so
um
I'm gonna go to the bottom table here
just to explain how you would see a
swept tax cut in a fiscal note because
what the fiscal note is really telling
you how the the state money works and
how it cost 100 million dollars so if we
reduce by The Sweat by 100 million
dollars we now have a hundred million
dollars less Revenue coming in on our
ledgers because we recorded as money
coming into our ledgers we also have 100
million dollars going out on our ledgers
because we recorded is going out on our
ledgers so that is net neutral to the
safe budget when you just cut swept
you've lost Revenue you lost an
expenditure it's net neutral to the
state budget where it actually the swept
tax cut costs the state money was how it
interacted with the adequacy formula so
84 million dollars went to communities
that were that
uh their cost of an adequate education
was greater than their uh was greater
than their swept and we had to cut them
a check 84 million dollars went out to
those communities and about 16 million
dollars went out to the communities
where their swept was above their cost
of an adequate education but the swept
dropped and we had to cut them a check
to bring them up to the two million
dollars that they had before
so that is how the state spent two
million 100 million dollars on the swept
tax cut the way it interacted with the
formula
um so it can get a little tricky and
Technical
um but that's that's that's uh that's
how this web tax cut works the next page
page seven is just a walkthrough of
examples on how you can kind of see how
the money flows and how it is a tax cut
and not actually um it's not decreasing
funding for school because the state's
paying the difference so for every swept
dollar you lost the state paid the
difference that holds your school
funding level and your property
taxpayers your sweat property taxpayers
are paying less so that's just
mechanically how it works is a tax cut
and if you have more questions about
that it can be I have some videos on it
but it can be kind of complicated
so actually your tax is going to go up
by about 50 cents this next year it's
not that 100 million dollars it's not
adjusted that that's um
that so when you when you when
relatively yes when you but what since
property values are going up it's only
going to go up a little it's going to go
up less than 50 cents because property
values are going up so you can raise
more money with a smaller tax rate but
yeah effectively you're correct
yeah I I've thought of this before and I
mean it was an odd thing when we were
talking about it last year and
it's tempting for me to describe this
basically as a sleight of hand in terms
of how taxpayers would have perceived
this because it was a one-year thing
there was no you know 100 million was
just instead of from here it was from
here but I mean nothing really changed
or tell me you know where it did change
but to me it just felt like a sleight of
hand of moving money around that really
didn't do much of anything for anybody
so it did change it changed nothing for
the school district the school district
um the the formula ran as it normally
would have essentially if you're
declining enrollment whatever it may
something could have else could have
impacted the formula but it had no
impact on school funding the only thing
at impact is when bills when tax bills
went out this fall this late late you
might have got your tax bill um Dr race
at the rates in late fall for most
communities
um it included a less of a swept Levy
than you would have had to pay in the
previous year
but the state ended up making that
difference correct yeah
since I'm new just to make sure I
understand correctly the net impact of
that is what was that no expenditure you
know was changed the disbursements were
the same but they say substituted 100
million of State dollars instead of a
hundred million dollars in property
local property taxes so that was you
know what this comes down to when you
boil down to it yes that's right it's
it's whatever the swept taxpayers were
raising that they normally would have
sent to the school we said take 100
million dollars off that and we'll pay
and we'll pay 100 million dollars thank
you
thank you
I would like to ask the question of what
we some of us wanted to do instead of
doing the swept rejection put a hundred
million dollars into the formula to
distribute to school districts what
difference would that have made
so
the it depends on how you would have
distributed it but
so with increasing state aid through the
adequacy formula
it could result in a tax cut assuming
districts keep their budget flat
um it would there's a lot of into the
tax form there's a lot of metrics that
go in variables that go into the tax
formula
um
the swept tax cut the way to think about
it is it was a flat tax cut across the
board so every swept taxpayer received a
reduction in their swept liability
essentially usually when you're doing
changes to the formula it's usually not
sometimes it's sometimes it could be
across the board but it's usually not
across the board so usually if you're
modifying the formula you have a
particular policy objective you're
trying to achieve where you're trying to
Target a particular Community like
disparity if we at a disparity yeah some
of the other modifications of the
formula have targeted F and R students
have targeted poor property towns have
targeted you might want to Target
English language Learners whatever if
you have a particular formula change
it's probably not going to be flat
across the board
thank you
thank you Mr chairman
um
English language learner and the there's
another one
can we still can you pay both
let's see oh yes uh uh the third grade
the third grade reading is the only
unique one that you have to um not be
any of the other three categories okay
right that's still an effect yes thank
you
I'm gonna move on to the fiscal year 24
formula
oh yep
finish the topic since uh this question
was asked in a hypothetical situation
where that restriction would be removed
on the literacy Aid do you have an idea
of what the impact would be how many of
those students would qualify for that
but don't get the funding because they
fall in one of the you know previous
three you may not have the answer of the
top of your head but
Yeah we actually just recently got this
question and just a ballpark
2000 I think
I think yeah so the total number of
eligible students are about 6 500 before
we you know
eliminate the ones that get other kinds
of Aid and then we can look at the
totals here all I need thank you yeah it
would jump from about a two million
dollar part of the formula to maybe like
eight million dollars so to remove that
it would cost approximately I just doing
some rough math probably six million
dollars
um fiscal year 24 the only changes in
fiscal year 24 are the swept hold
harmless Grant is gone away because the
swept tax has gone away so it's not
needed anymore because the swept is back
to what it was so if you were getting 2
million in your swept like you were
before the soap tax cut got uh uh into
effect you would receive it again so
there's no swept told harmless Grant and
there's also no swept tax cut the only
other thing and we'll talk a little bit
about this is there's no modification to
the fnr data
um in fiscal year 23 there was a
modification effort to the f r data to
bring it up to fiscal year 20 uh
school year 2020 levels essentially yeah
which were the pre-prandemic levels and
I think I have
I do have a handout further down to talk
about the way f r data is trending so
I'll talk about the challenges districts
have with fnr data
unless representative well should we
change the way we do that because of
things like the pandemic that have a big
effect because of people don't sign up
for free and reduced which happens a lot
it affects it affects the uh adequacy
that that's right
um so there's
um the fnr data our poverty data when we
had 167 000 students Statewide the fnr
numbers were 45
000.
um
now uh we have 160 000 students and then
in the next year we had 160 000 students
and the number dropped to
um 38 000. so it's still that's like a
12 decrease from the previous year even
though enrollment had a four percent
decrease and so representative Petri is
talking about is our fnr numbers are
decreasing at a rate that we know is
faster than what they're actually
decreasing at and a lot of that has to
do with the pandemic waivers that said
you don't need to fill out an
application to get me access to meals so
a lot of families didn't fill out the
application because there was nothing uh
they got the meals whether they fill out
the application or not so the fnr
numbers we've had a multiple work
sessions uh House Education house
finances work together to try to study
this issue
there's a lot of ways to tackle it
um although the position of the
department is
we try to work with supers and try to
stay on top of them and they know this
they know this and it's a challenge as
we try to get them to just understand
the importance of f r data
um it's not just the meals program it's
also part of the adequacy formula and
they get two thousand dollars for every
every f r student they can identify
so we really hammered home to the
districts that this is super important
and they know that and they work all
year to bring those numbers up they
still struggle it's still a challenge
for them to get those fnr numbers up to
get those applications in
um there is an idea that you'll likely
see in this committee um it's been here
before is Medicaid direct cert if it
goes from house education to the house
floor and then into this committee you
might see the idea that we can direct
certify uh we can identify a student in
poverty using Medicaid data that's an
issue that might get might end up in
this committee uh it's we Norm we we use
the DHHS data for TANF and snap
um to identify students in poverty and
then we have those systems look at NHS
data and we identify those students that
are on Snap or TANF and we automatically
identify them as eligible for free and
reduced price meals so they can get fed
in their school without filling out an
application and we can also include them
in the fnr formula for adequacy so we're
currently doing that with SNAP and TANF
um and then if you're on fiscal
committee you might know that snap has
now moved up from 185 percent
eligibility to 200 eligibility so that's
likely going to increase our snap
numbers which will in turn increase our
F and our numbers through direct
certification we don't know how much
DHHS has some numbers and then also
there's the Medicaid direct cert uh uh
there's legislation I believe in the
Senate and and the house
that would a lot if that if those bills
were to pass
um that would allow the department to
enter a program
um that's authorized by the center for
Medicaid services
um and also the United States Department
of Agriculture which would allow DHHS to
share Medicaid data with the Department
of Education and then use Medicaid data
to identify fnr students in addition to
snap and TANF so those are those are
some of the policy proposals that have
been thrown out there that are being
worked on and studied but yeah that's
that's been a long-standing issue the f
r challenges
thank you and thank you Mr chair and
just to make this even more complicated
because it wasn't complicated enough
um
my concern is that we have a certain
poverty level that we need to meet in
order to qualify for fnr and then we are
using the snap and tanifest proxies for
that to help us identify gaps in the
data but now that the eligibility level
of snap is changing
if we are still using snap does that
affect our original decision to use the
snap as a proxy for fnr when now people
had that you know do you see what I'm
saying there are two different
qualifying criteria and we may end up
counting I'm just trying to understand
again because there is a lot of detail
here yeah so
um that decision
I'm trying to think if it could be made
at the state level uh the state made the
decision through via the fiscal
committee to raise it to 200
um
that 185 number is a federal number
um so states can always kind of go above
and beyond the federal number
um but yeah that's it yeah it can get a
little complicated I guess I know I have
to know the exact um
I don't know when those decisions are
made or what was understood or the
intent of when those decisions were made
but certainly there are different ways
to look at the data
yeah I appreciate it it's it's honestly
it's
very complicated and one needs to wrap
their head around it and there is a lot
of there are a lot of moving parts that
we need to understand absolutely
I ask a question about direct
certification when we worked on that
what is what was the status that did it
did it not pass or did they did make it
over to the house but then it was uh
yeah I don't know what happens to it
when it goes oh sorry made it from the
house to the Senate but then the Senate
removed it oh
yeah right thank you
so that's fiscal year 24. if you look at
page nine this is adequacy history oh I
got 10 minutes left
um
uh I'll point out to um a lot to look in
here and study
um on your own time but I'll just point
to line 20 line 20 is stabilization so
we had some conversations about
stabilization and when it started to
decline
so actually now I can see from here in
fiscal year 20 uh 2017
um on page 20 you can see stabilization
went from 158 million to 151 million so
that was when there was a a sentence set
in law four percent reduction each year
and so it reduced down in 2018 reduced
down in 2019 and then it was brought
back up to essentially the full amount
in fiscal year 20. so that's kind of
been the the history of stabilization
um going to lines 21 to 26.
you'll see a lot of activity on
additional AIDS above and beyond the
cost of an adequate education these have
been the historical modifications to the
formula that have existed in the past
um
four years so every year the formulas
had a little Tinker with it a little
tweakier and there and this is kind of
the um
shows you how those adjustments have
been made some of them were enrollment
hold harmlesses some of them were
different relief programs some of them
were one time some of them were not one
time
but you'll what I told you for fiscal
year 23 and 24 is the current formula
foreign
there are a lot of phone calls coming
about
um because school districts are seeing a
decrease
um and primarily around the fnr because
of the hold because of the bill that we
pass or whatever it was that we did that
said that it would stay constant with
what it was in 2019 and now in 2024
school districts are seeing not only are
they not getting
um
as many free and reduced lunch students
they may have a dip in their own
enrollments so they're kind of getting a
double whammy so how do we what do we do
when school districts call us and say
how come I'm getting so much less money
is is that the response basically so
yeah that you must be getting them yeah
um
when and I have a spreadsheet here uh
fiscal year 23 which had an fnr
modification we paid 970 million
Statewide
um fiscal year 24 we're estimating it to
be 962 million so they're receiving
Statewide they're receiving an 8 million
dollar drop but also in that we have the
CPI adjustment so they might be having
declining enrollment and if we didn't do
a consumer price index inflation
adjustment to their rates they would see
a lot less in school funding because of
declining enrollments but if anyone's
receiving less money in fiscal year 24
than they did in 23 it's because of
either declining enrollment and it's
fnr's kind of the big it's fnr it's
either fnr bass because we kept spad in
our estimates we kept sped in English
language Learners constant but what's
confusing a lot of people is that big
adequacy check to cut to supplant what
they had for swept that is going away
and so that's where I've spent a lot of
time talking to supers talking to the
public explaining that your flat your
funding is actually flat but a tax cut
was there and goes away and so some
people say well you're cutting back
funding and I go well no your funding is
flat or what's going down a little bit
maybe because of enrollment decline but
the swept is going up
so it's a challenge
so moving moving on to page 10 um kind
of what I've been I've been showing this
document to districts to what
representative Heath was discussing
um this is where districts are getting
tripped up with the swept tax cut the
swap tax cut is
it is hard to explain to people um
oh you got it representative yeah what
took the place with the swept was that
was just Surplus wasn't it
um okay I just wanna
anyway yeah it was it was because
politically we're gonna cut we're going
to cut swept tax but we didn't cut it we
just took Surplus and made and and and
swapped it I can't keep track of exactly
what was said on the senate floor when
it when the sub tax cut left this
committee or left to this chamber
um you use 62 million in general funds
to pay for it so you didn't fund it just
off education trust fund you put 62
million dollars from the general fund
into the education trust fund to pay for
it
um and then when the Senate looked at
the same tax cut they said the revenues
what you know the revenues always go up
when they go to the Senate you know um
they always have more money than you
um they said they didn't need the 62
million uh they said they could do it
just with the education trust fund so
that's that's the only thing that I can
speak to is they paid for it all out of
the education trust fund and the
education trust fund still ended with a
surplus
um actually I didn't point out there but
the education trust fund Surplus for
fiscal year 22 was 100 million
um that's it yeah well this is this is
the actual it's not the estimated but
yes
um the the surpluses there's there's
surpluses in the education trust fund
and uh what was that on the senate floor
I don't exactly recall thank you thank
you
and and so on page 10 is kind of what
I've been showing districts to explain
the shift in swept to adequacy so State
total fiscal year 23 is that 970 million
um and then if you look at fiscal year
24 it's 962 million so you're kind of
sort of flat funded but you'll see there
is the adequacy amount that's the state
check so it's 707 million in a state
check in fiscal year 23 and then only
600 million in a state check and fiscal
year uh 24 so that's the 100 million
dollar swept tax cut essentially plus
some declining enrollment so that's
that's an easy way to well I don't know
if there's an easy way to explain to
voters or citizens or taxpayers but
that's what I've been using it's the
best one the best way to explain it I
got
um
just to move quickly page 14
this shows you total pupils that's
really ADM this is by municipality
um so when you see there this shows you
declining enrollment so most towns are
seeing declining enrollments if you've
got a number in parentheses you have
declining enrollment so this just shows
you the ADM Trends so we went from 167
000 7 000 students to now we're
estimating a 150 eventually 157 000 and
school year 22 which is that um
um which is the 23 formula
uh I might have my
uh numbers off on that I have to double
check that
um so it's a 10 000 enrollment drop
uh
in and then F and R you're seeing the
same thing we're seeing a decline in fnr
we had 45
000 down to 38 000 so uh declining F and
R as well
um and that's some of the that's somehow
the data shakes out
so you can see if your town is losing
students or gaining students
almost yeah General Trends Statewide is
decline so a few some communities I
think see are seeing some some growth
so the last document is kind of
technical
uh
is kind of technical
um if you go to page 19 or this is the
second to last document this is a
district by District sort of
um I don't know you want to call it a
report card or or dashboard
um but the First Column is your cost per
pupil so cost per pupil is just
essentially current expenditures over
how many students your District educates
so some districts that don't have
students have zero cost per pupil
because they don't it's meant to be the
operations of your schools that's what
this measure is is showing Facebook
based on the doe 25 the financial
reports we receive
oh
so when when districts when districts
finish their fiscal when if they finish
their fiscal year on September 1st a lot
of them don't make it by September 1st
some districts do
um they have to complete something
called the doe 25 which is uh it has a
balance sheet a district balance sheet
and it has all revenues and expenditures
the district has spent it has
information about the trust funds it
actually has 2500 pieces of data that we
require the districts to give to us
is financial data it has some
supplemental information we can learn a
little bit about how much sped cost is
in districts
we use this document primarily to set
taxes we need to know how much money
they're going to lapse back to the
taxpayers
um so we have them record all the
revenue expenditures and we know how
much if they have a profit essentially a
surplus they might keep that and we need
to they tell us if they're going to keep
some of it if they have the authority to
keep some of it or if they're going to
send some of it back to the taxpayers so
that's the doe 25 it's used in the tax
rate setting process it's also data
collection for my office so we have some
analytical tools so if you ask for
information I can tell you if it's on
the doe 25 and if we can analyze it for
you we can run reports through our
database
I apologize I've got to leave oh okay
right I I have a question yep yeah like
our uh warrant for last year showed uh
we spent about twenty two thousand
dollars per student
and this is showing about nine uh what
000 and some change why why is there
such a disparity or just you can't
probably tell that I I yeah I don't know
their methodology they could have had a
different methodology than us
um
mm-hmm
so oh oh so what they're using
Appropriations over pupils which are
that's going to be higher likely
or what did you say the number was for
that 22 000.
yeah so if they're doing Appropriations
they're assuming they're going to spend
every penny of that appropriation but
usually there's a lapse at the end of
the year so that could be that could be
the reason also
yeah
um it's a little apples and oranges it's
going to be a they're guessing
essentially too when they do a worn
article they don't know
they don't know
yeah they might be local they might be
lowballing the grants which is sometimes
you want to do that because you want to
uh make sure you have enough money yeah
just a quick follow-up to the same
question I was gonna ask it too because
uh I live in Windham and we've been
consistently around or over 18 000 the
students and this report shows us at 16.
so I guess the easiest way to answer to
that could you maybe share the exact
methodology used by your department to
calculate the cost per pupil and you
know that would make it very easy for us
to figure out where the differences are
at least get us a starting point because
obviously we don't want to belabor this
right now but it would be useful to
understand the apparent discrepancy yes
yeah we have a particular methodology
that's on the doe 25 but yes well uh
it's um we back out a few things
um so whether Windows doing that that
likely does it yep
um just to die this is for your own
homework if you want to study how these
districts work
um we have a local Revenue percentage so
how much of their revenue is local by
District how much of their revenue is
state by District how much the revenue
is federal by district and then we have
um
um if you want to kind of get into the
policy details of this we have an
assessed tax rate versus an equalized
tax rate and so some of you might get
your tax bill and you want to look at
your tax rate and you want to look at
your neighbor's tax rate and you want to
go wise there's less than ours or why is
there uh yeah why is there less than
ours you know I want a lower tax rate
and so that's a if you go to the diy's
website that's an alright methodology to
compare your tax rate to your neighbors
but a better methodology is a document
that the department publishes where we
look at not
whenever dra publishes that tax rates
it's based on the assessed property in
your town
and your your town might have a distant
different assessing process than your
neighboring town so if you want to
control and say let's just use market
value for properties and let's actually
try to have the best apple to Apple
comparisons you could look at the
equalized tax rate so as you'll see
Statewide the equalized tax rate median
is 17 per thousand where with the
assessed tax rate median is 21 per
thousand so what that means is
districts are assessors are basically
Under reporting their property to
compare relative to market value so they
need a higher tax rate and raise the
money they actually need so this is
really technical but if you really want
to compare your neighbors and how
they're doing on a tax rate by tax rate
basis we have a document on our website
you can use this document to sort of
just get a flavor of where how you stack
up to your neighbors because it controls
for assessing practices between
different towns
and so I know we're running out of time
here I've got Caitlin here to talk about
um efas real quick
I'm sorry
or maybe just take a five minute well
he's he's I believe he's left for the
day he has to take care of his uh wife
so
uh whatever you want to do
yeah I think it would be
if I could just speak on behalf of the
newbies this was a lot of information to
take in today and to open another big
topic
might be overload so if we don't mind
deferring to have the chair come back I
wouldn't mind doing this another day so
I can digest this go back and watch the
video a second time and make sure I
didn't miss anything
very good Don and I believe Caitlyn said
she'd come back another day so and
and you know and I I speak for the
committee but I think today has been
very enlightening there's a lot of
information that we didn't have uh and
uh really appreciate you being here
thank you
very good
so is there anything else
anybody else I tell you this is you know
and many of us have been and seen this
before and it's it's a lot to take in
but uh
you know the detail like the swept the
swept was
that's something we haven't had and
that's very hard you know it gets to be
difficult to understand but you you get
it it's not a it's not a big deal
thankfully I have a little bit of
insight from the Ways and Means
Committee talking about swept but I do
think today's
um discussion was very helpful thank you
very good I guess I guess we're done for
the day and we'll see you tomorrow and
uh hey have a great evening
well if you if you use a mic we're on
camera
appreciate that I just wanted to say on
behalf of the department
time to listen to us we are obviously
very passionate about the work that we
do and very knowledgeable and throughout
either just the typical legislative
process and the budget process we are
here to support the committee and all of
the needs that you might have relative
to our topic so please don't feel free
or please don't feel bad about reaching
out and asking us because we we really
do want to make sure that you all have
the information you need when making
important decisions well we're very
lucky to have the people that support us
thank you they're fabulous
thank you
foreign